You just started that shit now?
Yeah, everyone's like, NOOOOO!
And then I just went live.
No, don't be live!
Hello to my chat.
Is anyone else live other than me and Jay?
I think Gomez was gonna.
Oh yeah, that's true.
And if I was going to, then we'd be fucking excited.
Guys, if you guys are like...
I think Kony's gonna be live too.
If you guys are like, what happened to...
We had to kick Beto out of the voice chat because they maxed out our voice chat group thing because we have seven players.
And they were like, we want to make sure nobody stream snipes.
And I was like, what the fuck do you...
We have so much to lose.
It's like, what?
Oh, they gave the group UIDs.
You have it?
You see it?
Wait, the group UIDs?
Okay, so this is the...
Sorry, you have to invite this person.
Oh, can I leave the practice round at this point?
Well, Gomez is making it, so...
I'm waiting for him to invite me in.
Oh, there's Kony!
Hey, Kony!
Howdy, y'all.
Kony, what's up, man?
Hello, Kony.
I'm sorry Beto can't be in here with us.
I'm sorry for kicking him out.
Are you actually sorry, though?
I'm supposed to be in here!
We're a team!
Am I supposed to add this person?
You're supposed to invite this person into the...
Yeah, invite this person in.
Well, they're in a custody and I can't invite them.
Wait, what?
They didn't invite us.
No, I can't invite them.
What the fuck?
Do I have them?
I guess so.
They didn't add me to any lobbies.
I'm, like, waiting to be added.
I just request to join in.
That's it.
Wait, that worked.
Okay.
No, this is my lobby.
They're supposed to be going in our lobby because we're the top.
I'm so confused.
Yeah, I'm just waiting for them to...
Uh...
I'm just waiting for them to invite me or, like...
Um, let's see.
Who the fuck is in Dead Brain Cells?
I don't know.
The leader...
The captain of our Dead Brain Cells...
Um...
Is in a custom lobby and we can't invite them.
Okay, I wrote that.
I just wrote that in the group A general.
Unless we're getting casted.
I don't know whose matches are getting casted.
I...
I don't know.
Is there... Did they put, like, a thing for us to look at?
Like, group A?
Is it group A?
Oh, look.
Looking at the group A stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We are at... We...
Um...
Oh, wait.
We... Yeah, we told... I messaged it and they're, like...
They, like... They added the team.
Why couldn't they add the team and we can?
I feel like we should... I don't know.
We were gonna be Team Brain Cells.
Wow, you suck.
I was, like, trying to, like, add roles, but we don't have the proofs to add roles.
So, like...
I'm, like, a little... Okay.
I'm also, like... I had two hours of sleep, guys.
So, like, I'm more... I'm more, like, frustrated.
You know, like, more frazzled up right now.
So, I was trying... We were trying to add the admins, but we can't add the admin roles.
And then, like... So, we were, like...
We had to individually add the mods and the admins to ask questions.
And I'm, like, I wish I could just add the roles.
It's so awkward.
It's definitely a little messy.
Yeah.
They're, like, please start your games.
We got help.
Oh, my God.
Who am I supposed to invite?
You're supposed to... The one I sent you.
The one I sent you.
That's a caster, though, is it not?
No, it's not.
That's... No, the one I sent you.
The UID.
That's not a caster.
That's the team... The captain.
They're level two.
What?
No, I sent you... I sent you a UID.
I sent you a UID.
No way.
Yeah, yeah.
Copy and paste the UID in the friends list.
You'll see.
They're level two.
There's no way.
Okay, wait.
Oh, my God.
This is awkward.
Wait, try... Oh, wait.
Do this.
Oh, they fucked up the... Okay, wait.
No, they fucked it up.
Okay, it's actually this.
And this one.
No, they, like... The order was different.
No, it's this one.
Oh.
Okay, now I can invite them.
Okay, thank God.
All right.
Fucking worried.
We did it.
Wait, how about maps?
The maps are... Oh, my God.
Where is it?
There's too many servers, guys.
There's too many... There's too many, like, announcements.
Which shadow was it?
They said the map.
I don't remember.
There's so many.
I'm looking as well.
Oh, Convergence.
Central Park.
I figured it out.
I found it.
It's in Grand Cup.
Guys, there's so many channels, guys.
There's a lot.
Convergence, Central Park.
Yeah.
Did anyone not look at the schedule before yesterday, by the way?
No, I looked at...
I didn't realize this was at 11 a.m.
Most of these are, like, you know, like, West Coast focused.
So, like, East Coast, I'm like... Yeah, I'm like, okay, I'll start this at, like, 4 a.m.
No, this is East Coast slash EU focused.
Oh, yuck.
I got baited, too, because I thought it was 11 a.m.
PT, so I was thinking this whole time, oh, damn, okay, I can get streaming, like, this entire weekend before.
And then, like, I realized, oh, shit, wait, that's, like, 8 a.m.
my time.
Okay, I guess I'm not streaming.
Yeah, no, it runs straight down my stream.
It's like, okay, never mind.
Surprisingly, there's a lot of EU players in this tournament.
I think that's why it's, like, super early.
What is Central Park?
Yay, good for you, love.
You got the EU hours, finally.
I don't know about that.
I had to wake up earlier than I usually would for this.
Did you choose any time schedule at this point?
Yeah, pretty much.
When I was in LA for Anime Expo, that was more natural for me than life.
They're ready whenever, by the way.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Is it normal Vans?
Is it that?
Yes, it's the one we've been doing.
Okay, perfect.
Are you ready?
Are we ready?
Yeah, we're ready.
Okay, we're good.
Wait, wait, we didn't invite Beto.
Oh my god.
I mean, I invited him.
I fucking invited him.
Let's just fucking get him in.
Let's go.
We're gonna get in trouble for this.
Yeah, let's just go.
We'll just be like, we didn't know.
If they accuse Beto of stream sniping, we'll be like, really?
I'll be like, bro, what the fuck is Beto gonna do?
Careful, careful.
He might pick Magneto.
Dude, I did look at a little bit of their team, and they just have a Loki one trick and a Bucky one trick.
That's the scariest thing, and that's all.
Oh, they banned Strange.
Oh, wow, okay.
Let's just ban Bucky.
Fuck it.
If they have a Bucky one trick, we'll get rid of it.
Yeah, fuck them.
And we'll keep...
Beat that guy.
I don't know.
Luna, safer thing.
I think, like, just do Luna, just because, like, we don't really have anything we want to protect, to be honest.
They might protect Loki, maybe.
Yeah, fuck it.
Let them protect Loki.
Oh, Storm?
Storm, alright.
Alright, what should our next ban be?
Oh, the motherfuckers did the research.
I didn't do the research.
What about them?
I mean, I didn't research them.
I was not...
No, they're all private.
Let's just ban Loki.
Loki, right?
Loki one trick?
Yeah.
Okay, just ban Loki.
I mean, yeah, I have Namor open, so I'm fine.
Yeah, just ban it.
Oh, I need my glasses.
You weren't wearing glasses?
Yeah, I'm just chillin'.
You're gonna chill?
You don't take our tournament seriously.
With Slytherin, Ben, do you want me on Adam or Sue?
Adam.
Adam?
Alright.
Well, let's go Adam first.
Are we attacking or defending?
Oh, okay, we're attacking.
Yeah, it's fine.
We can swap if it doesn't work out.
So, they're probably gonna play Storm, so I guess if Loki doesn't have ult, we just do a soul bond and heal through it.
Yeah.
I'll just sprint into everybody and be like, save me.
They'll be like, why am I here?
Oh, we're defending!
I can swap between Mag and Venom.
Yeah, we'll see how they're running.
See how it goes.
If I can fuck up their backlines, I'll probably swap to Venom.
Okay.
Alright, I'll give this to Coney.
Thank you!
Alright, let's see how this game goes.
We're gonna be playing safe.
Just wait for them to come around the corner.
Alright.
We can take just a lot of damage.
If I need to, if I get tired, I'll get gamer stuff soon.
Alright.
I don't know this map, like, at all, so...
What do you mean?
We've been scrimming on this map, Coney!
What the fuck do you mean?
They have the squirrel.
Doesn't mean I know it.
Mag on the right as well.
Alright.
I can't heal you.
Okay.
They have Muna as well.
Muna and Stormwind.
Oh, their Stormwind is low.
I'm trying to kill Storm.
I have no shields, by the way.
No shields.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, kill one, kill one, kill one.
I'm on him, I'm on him, I'm on him.
I got Storm, I got Storm, I got Storm, I got Storm.
Huge.
I'm on their healer right now.
Squirrel's dead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can shield you up.
Go mess.
I'm just being... I'm just healing.
Just doing my thing.
I think I should get more than two hours of sleep.
Now, I know why people sleep.
Okay, guys.
After this team, I might make some...
Oh, shit.
Go, go, go.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay, okay.
Oh, D.C.
D.C.?
Oh, shit.
How does that work?
Wait, who D.C.?
I mean, they're on attack, so we could, like, not...
We just chill.
We just pull back and chill, then.
I guess.
I don't know.
What was the D.C.
rules?
I don't remember.
If it's before first kill, they'll remake.
If it's after first kill, it's just normal.
But, like, I'm down to remake.
Like, it just depends on time.
I don't care.
We'll just...
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Alright, we'll just wait.
Okay, just there?
Okay, alright.
Alright, alright.
I'll take it.
Alright.
Okay, alright.
I think the obvious choice is to not remake.
Why did he ask if we want to?
You're the one...
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Bro, okay, same bans.
Okay, that's good.
At least he lands at the same bans.
At least, you know.
Alright, let's just...
Alright.
Oh, my god.
Again.
First kill.
Come on, man.
Alright.
The least we could do is...
We've got a very strong team.
Okay.
No, I just say, like...
They didn't have to be like, should we remake?
Yeah, I don't know about all that.
Yeah.
I think after that, they're not allowed to have a second remake, right?
I don't know if Coney read the rule.
Yeah.
Coney did the research.
Holy shit, though.
I did, because my game keeps crashing.
So, if I...
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
I said that we don't have to...
They took our one remake.
What the...
We'll just be like...
What I'm gonna do is...
Oh, we used ours?
I'm gonna restart.
No, no.
They used theirs.
They used...
I think each team has a remake, right?
So, they used theirs.
So, then we should have our own remake.
Okay.
That's fine.
We'll just be like...
Lime.
Lime, move over.
Okay.
I was like, which button is it?
And then I saw the join button.
Yeah.
On its own.
Okay.
I am inviting Bettle in.
No, no.
Bettle can't watch.
Oh, he can't?
They kicked him out?
Yeah, they kicked him out.
Wait, who said that?
Look in our chat.
Wait, but he's not on the call.
Why is he not allowed to watch?
I don't know.
He was told he couldn't?
What's he gonna do?
Talk to me.
What's this?
I guess he can just watch.
You're stuck to...
He's stuck to viewing our streams.
Oh, man.
I guess he has to watch the stream, yeah.
Yeah, he has to watch the stream.
I'm gonna start it right away.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Let's get it.
Let's go.
Okay, I just asked them.
Okay, we asked R and I didn't wait.
They're scared of Bettle.
He's just so scary.
That was our caster, though.
Why are we doing this again?
What?
My bad.
Honestly, I might just go Bucky.
We banned Bucky, bro.
Yeah, we banned.
Yeah, because he had a Bucky and...
No, they said same ban, too.
I can't believe it.
Bettle has to be the scariest team member in our team.
Okay, which heroes will get my cosmic favor today?
Look how coney was like, you're in jail.
We put Bettle in jail.
He can't play.
Not allowed.
I can't believe they won't...
Like, I get it.
But like, come on, bro.
He's just a clown.
He can stream one of our streams.
He's just a little guy.
Yeah, he has to watch our streams like a fucking pleb.
Oh, dude.
Not that you guys are plebs, dear viewers.
Not that you guys.
Yeah, we're not talking about you guys.
Not you.
Dude, I almost forgot that he would just pull up one of our streams.
Apparently he's scared of watching our streams because he doesn't want to get in trouble.
Because I was going to be like, hey, maybe I could just call you and like, FaceTime it.
Just FaceTime it.
Wait, that's stupid.
What am I talking about?
Just have your phone to your monitor and be like, Bettle, do you see this?
But then like, then you talk to yourself to his stream.
Right, I forgot.
There's a lot of things that didn't get considered for that plan.
Appreciate the sentiment behind it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just like, let me dox myself for Bettle real quick.
Alright, here we go again.
Wait, they're running a different character now.
They changed up their comp.
They changed up the comp, bro.
Oh, did they?
No, they did.
No, no, no.
Oh, me?
I have no shields, Coney, careful.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I'm healing it.
What is this?
Shields in 5, shields in 5.
Okay.
I see you, Foggy.
I have to reload.
There's a rocket on you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm here.
Okay, I'm reloading.
Oh shit.
Help Jay, help Jay.
I have no shields, I have no... I'm good.
Yeah, no bubble, no bubble.
Bubble in 8.
I have ult here, but I'm going to save it for aggressive ults.
I mean, defensive ults.
Yeah, I have bubble in 1.
Spider-Man on you, Gomez!
This might be the first game on.
Okay, this might be the first game on.
Oh, I got him, I got him, I got him.
Good trick, good trick, good trick.
I'm going to Sly Locka.
One more comfort.
I'm winning, I'm winning, I'm winning, I'm winning.
I am ready to run.
How did that...
I have bubble for you.
I got Jay, I got Jay, I got Jay.
Oh no, oh no.
I can block it, maybe.
I got it, I got it, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Nice ult bomb, nice ult bomb.
Nice.
Good shit.
Good name or shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pudge him, pudge him, pudge him.
Get him, get him, get him, get him.
Oh, I got him.
We got him!
Damn it.
That's fucking right.
This is for Bettle.
He might not be able to see this, but it's for you, Bettle.
You can watch the recordings afterwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll give him the replay.
We'll give him the replay code and we'll watch this later.
You see that?
That was plural.
That was for you.
Yeah, yeah.
That was all for you, Bettle.
I'm good.
Yeah, bro.
Bro, you're chilling, man.
You're chilling.
I'm fine.
Bubble in seven.
Careful there.
Seven.
Oh, you guys are so healthy.
I mean, they're not really pushing up.
I'm just going in.
Yeah, you're just going in, beating them up.
I might need heals.
Back, back, back.
Can you stab me here?
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
I have no bubble for the bubble.
I used my bubble.
I'm good.
Oh, I'm backing up.
All right.
I have my ult, yeah.
I have ult again.
Oh, rocket.
Rocket.
Yeah, I'm with your rocket.
Is bubble down, huh?
It's almost dead.
Oh, I'm on.
Oh, shit.
I got you.
Spidey.
I'm back.
Spawned in it.
Whoa, we're all healthy.
We're all...
Oh my god.
We're less healthy now.
You might have to get ready for one more.
Oh, shit.
I just might have to get ready.
I think it's cool.
Yeah.
You're slamming.
You're clobbering.
Big clobber.
Good clobber.
But I am not healthy.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, shit.
Spidey found me.
I got it off, but Spidey found me.
I'm frozen.
I'm roofing the shop.
I got Spidey.
We gotta eat somebody.
Okay, good shit.
It's a warm-up.
It's a warm-up, baby.
This is not looking good for you.
It's a warm-up.
First game.
Damn.
What happened?
Ready, Wash?
Spiderman?
Yo, bro, what the hell is he doing?
Bro, what's going on, bro?
I was like, alright, let me go up there and hug him.
Wait, what?
Wait, I think he's lost.
He's been in really weird places all game.
Yeah.
He sneaked in, bro.
Yeah, he's being a sneaky little guy.
Nice one.
Alright.
Nice, alright.
Nice.
Zero.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Damn.
Alright.
We're gonna play for attack.
I'm Luna Snow.
Same.
Actually, yeah.
I'm okay with doing this.
I'll try and flank.
Hello.
Oh, he's on Psylocke, though.
So, we'll both do it.
I have him on Psylocke.
I'm gonna do whatever.
Oh, you know what?
I could just bully the tank if I wanted to.
Yeah, let's just do that.
I'll put the orb on.
Yeah, you'll get ult-charged.
You'll get your ult-charged faster.
And then you just go around.
I'll put the orb on...
I'll put the orb on Gomez.
I need...
I need Coney to just throw me around.
Oh, yeah!
Let's get it!
I'm throwing you off the map, bro.
No!
Where's the fireplace, bro?
You're fucking lucky there's no fireplace in here.
I'm taking you to bed, bro.
We're going to bed.
What?
I'm watching you.
Good night.
It's all watch, guys.
It's all watch.
Oh, look at that.
No, where'd he go?
Coney, where are you?
In the bed, Coney.
What happened?
Coney, come on.
He was waiting for you.
The entire team watching.
Alright, I'm going to throw you and then I'm going to E to you and we're just going to kill the whole backline.
Oh, yeah.
And then we get the point.
That sounds so simple.
Where the hell is the... I don't understand this.
Alright, we're going around the corner.
I'm full sending.
Alright, go, go.
Alright, let's get it.
Oh, my God.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
Wait, you guys killed somebody?
Cloak half, cloak half.
Okay, we're all fine.
We're all still healthy, guys.
I don't know what the fuck happened, but you guys are awesome.
We're all healthy.
That's all that matters.
I got Hela.
Hela's dead.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
What happened?
She was standing way forward.
I hit her with half of my right click and then Wolverine jumped on her.
I picked Wolverine literally one shot.
I threw Wolverine at somebody's face and they died.
She was at half because I hit her with my right click.
Oh, my God.
You fucked that poor guy.
That poor 30k heal.
Jesus Christ, that was such a short game and I still got 30k healing.
You did 30k?
What the fuck?
Yeah, Coney was feeding hard, you can tell.
Alright, let's get beddled in here.
Alright.
Alright, goodbye, Jay.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
You can't spectate.
Get out of here.
Yeah, get out, Jay.
Yeah, get out.
Learn our strats, Jay.
Yeah.
Yeah, Jay.
We don't want you to cheat.
Oh, wait.
He's gone.
Beddle, get in here.
Welcome back, Beddle.
Alright, how did we do?
Oh, we lost.
We did pretty good.
We lost the first match, but you're here to make sure we win the next one, right?
Yeah, that's me.
Yeah, don't worry.
That would be a shame if we lost.
You tag me in and we lose.
What was their next map again?
I don't remember.
Okay, it's in the Grand Cup info.
It's Convoy Midtown.
Yeah, I got it.
Alright, cool.
I got the list pulled up.
Oh, nice.
Okay, so I don't have to tell you anything.
Nah, nah, nah.
They let Beddle out of jail?
Okay, welcome back.
Come here.
Hi, Beddle.
Welcome back, Beddle.
Beddle, are you ready?
Have you thought about your sins and crimes?
You paid your dues to society.
Yeah.
They let me back out into the city.
Yeah, you're on probation right now.
One wrong move and you're going back to jail.
Surely they won't ban Mag, right?
They won't do research on Beddle, right?
No.
Surely not.
They let Jay play Mag.
Did you just say fuck Bucky again?
Yeah, just fuck Bucky.
Yeah.
Oh, they don't know!
They don't know we have zero strange players!
Do we protect Mag?
Yeah, just protect Mag.
I mean, this is our last game against this team.
Protect Starlord?
Oh, wait, Starlord!
Wait, wait, protect Starlord.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Protect Starlord.
Let him do it.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How would they know?
If they ban Mag or Gavus here, they'll got a tank.
Well...
That's why I said it.
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
We're taking that risk.
You're gonna see my first time Groot in the middle of the game.
This is the risk we're willing to take.
There's no way.
I'd rather just ban Luna.
They aren't familiar with our...
Exactly.
They're not familiar.
How would they know?
Unless they pull up one of our...
Oh, see?
Yeah, you know what?
There we go.
They just ban Luna.
That's fine.
Luna's dead.
What was it?
Loki, right?
Yeah, we could do Loki.
Unless you wanna play it or like...
No, we play...
We can play...
Ban Loki and we'll do Adam Su.
Adam Su.
Okay.
Alright, let's do it.
Alright, I'll do Adam and then you run Su.
Let's get it.
Well, we kept Hela safe.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright, convoy time.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
I've been ready.
I have like four or five hours of sleep.
You know, I didn't even ask.
He had more sleep than me.
That's what I wanna hear.
I'm drinking gamer subs after this match, that's for sure.
I realized, like...
I was like, I can...
You know, like when you hit the...
I thought that would hit the peak where like...
You're tired.
You're so tired that you have so much energy.
But like, I'm not at that stage right now.
I'm definitely not at that stage.
You relied on the second wind, you fool.
Yeah, I thought I had the second wind.
And then I looked at him, I was like, my eyes are tired.
I was like, oh fuck.
My eyes are tired.
It's okay, you don't have to focus for like another four hours.
You'll be fine.
Yeah, we just have to go for...
We have to play five other teams.
You'll be fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It'll be so okay.
Alright, I have Beto's volume, so...
How many games is it per team?
It's two matches per team.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's Spiderman.
Um, I don't know, man.
Okay.
I'm the captain, but I don't know.
Yeah.
There's really nothing for my character to do here.
I'm just chillin'.
Hey, Penny!
Yeah, I do.
You know, they're trying to anti-dive.
I'm low.
I'm assuming that Limeo is healing you guys.
Heal.
Whoa!
I need to heal myself.
Don't look at you!
Whoa!
Okay, I've dropped down, Lime.
Yeah, I'm down, I'm down.
What hit you?
I don't know.
That's the one thing I don't like, is Penny against thing, because I just get fucking netted over and over.
So, that's what I'm worried about, but...
Wait, Spidey.
I got him.
He's right there.
Okay.
Is he low?
Nah.
I did hit him once.
I hit him once.
Oh yeah.
Oh, he got shielded.
Oh, I could've killed him.
Yeah, I was trying to shoot him too.
On top, Hella on top.
Alright, I'll go for the Hella.
Oh my god, I almost got her head.
I'm flying away.
Okay.
Can you heal?
I don't have snaps, I don't have snaps.
I got it.
You, like, flew the moment I snapped.
I'm gonna try to break the...
It's right there.
I see it.
Yeah, I'm breaking it, I'm breaking it right now.
It's broken.
Coney, give me...
Oh, wait, no.
Nevermind, you're on point.
Okay, I have...
Oh, shoot.
They're gonna have Spider-Man ult here.
Do you want me to ult it though, Gabe?
Um, I just ult on it first.
Okay.
I got Claw up.
I'm gonna ult.
Yeah, fuck this.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
There's two?
I thought you would pop defense ult.
I popped...
Yeah, I didn't pop any defensive ult for that.
He popped zero ults, by the way.
So, we should use nothing.
Alright, let's clear.
Good job, good job.
Um, the Spider-Man is most likely trying to scout me out for a rez.
So, that's gonna be an issue.
He did run me down when I rezzed you the last time.
Yeah, yeah.
I think that he's just gonna be trying to find me.
Oh, he's low, he's low.
Oh my god, bro.
Get the fuck back here.
Are you guys okay?
Where did he go?
There he is!
I'm chasing him.
Get him, boys!
After him!
Crush that Spider-Man!
I want pictures of Spider-Man right now!
I want pictures of Spider-Man!
I have ult after this.
Good shit.
You're fine!
You're so healthy.
I don't know... oh yeah, he's healthy too.
I'm so low, I'm so low.
I'm so low.
I'm so low!
Oh, you have regen.
I'm dead.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh shit, they're all here.
Make sure I'm alive.
Actually, actually, big rez.
Am I in this?
Yes, you are.
You might have to use ult for this.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I should have said use ult the moment they rez.
I shouldn't have messed with the amazing Spider-Man.
That's on me.
That's my bad.
I don't have soulbond for this.
I have clobber.
Oh, bro, I got bullied there.
Damn it.
That's fine.
I have clobber, you got nothing up.
I have soulbond, I have soulbond.
I might soulbond in it.
Alright, I'm here.
Hold on.
Shit.
I got separated!
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you!
I soulbonded, I soulbonded.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, I got Q for this.
Pushing up.
I'm touching, I'm touching, I'm touching.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, go, go, go.
Oh my god, huge!
It's huge!
Go, go, go, go!
It always is!
Oh my god, it's huge!
Oh, my ults are huge!
Nice.
Alright, good shit.
Nice, nice.
Oh, hey, there's Spider-Man.
Get his pictures right now.
Dox him.
Oh my god, he's so good.
He's a menace.
He's a menace to society.
Dox him right now.
He's gonna touch her.
Oh wait, true, he's gonna touch.
He's not gonna touch.
I can't wait till they add Jonah Jameson.
I'm playing as him.
He's gonna fucking do it.
Hard counter Spider-Man.
Get a hard counter.
He doxes Spider-Man and he just removes him from the game.
You have to go in hiding.
Yeah, he just turns into Peter Parker.
No character can steal you for the next 20 seconds.
You just have to go hide in a room.
I can't wait.
Let me up Beto's volume a little bit more.
Dude, I can up mine on my end if need be.
No, it's alright.
You were like at 100 earlier, so I have plenty of room to up you.
I can't wait for Professor Xavier.
To be a character.
In his fucking wheelchair.
There's a lot of stairs in this game.
It's gonna be a hover wheelchair, okay guys?
It's gonna be a hover wheelchair.
Well, if it's just his skin though.
He has different drip for his wheelchair.
True.
Oh my god.
That'll be so fucking cool.
He drips out his wheelchair.
Depending on the skin.
I just wanted to like...
Cause he's gonna be a support.
So I'm like, what the fuck is he gonna do?
How is he gonna heal his teammates with mental power?
I guess he has...
It's morale.
Yeah, like his encouragement.
He makes you think you're okay.
By controlling your like...
Your one nine hulk player.
You can do it.
Positive reinforcement.
You're not dying.
Woah, woah, woah.
This guy's gonna die.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't...
Okay, I got your snap.
I'm just gonna give you soul bond for this.
Just cause like...
Penny's one, Penny's one by the way.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, he's getting healed, he's getting healed.
Wait, why are you Iron Fist?
Oh, I kinda felt like it.
Come on.
I think he could die.
I got one.
I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you.
Solo healer, by the way.
Woah, I got picked off.
I'm getting fucking punched.
It's fine, Adam's an amazing solo healer.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I am solo healing right now.
I got got there.
Get that hulk, he's one.
I'm surprised by how long I survived as a solo healer.
What if I just ult in front of everybody?
Actually, nothing would go wrong.
Okay.
I'm gonna hold my ult for a long time so I can...
Bro is meditating.
So I can ult after line ult.
Keep going, Coney.
Holy shit.
Keep going?
Yeah, keep going.
Keep punching him.
Keep going?
Keep fucking punching.
Okay.
There's a magneto on us.
There's a magneto here.
We got him.
Nice.
We did it.
Nice, huge.
Nice, we did it.
Yay, we're going with the first game.
Okay.
GG.
We're going back to bench.
That's like a hair.
Okay.
Yay.
When does the next round start?
I don't even know.
Wait, let me look at the schedule.
We need to know if the other team is done playing too.
I'm gonna look at the challenge so we can tell if they're done.
Because I don't even...
Oh yeah, we have to report our games.
Bro, battle damage.
Wait.
Damn.
Wait, let me see.
Oh my god.
You got blocked by the snake.
That was our secret weapon.
Wait, you did more than me.
Yeah, you did more than...
You know what?
Maybe battle should replace you.
I did not expect you to do more damage than us.
Please do not tell my team this.
Don't worry.
I'll tell his team this.
Alright, how do I report our fucking games?
I'm learning this as we go along, guys.
Where the fuck...
Oh, group A.
Also, Jay found out that you can't actually watch the stream, so that's nice.
You can?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Benno, you can watch the stream.
You can't spectate, but you can...
I'll watch from afar.
Someone in my chat said Gomez used the morale skill on Coney and they killed everyone.
Gomez definitely popped his ult.
He told me to fight, and we did.
We killed him.
Oh wait, okay.
I'm gonna open up Coney's stream because we're supposed to post screenshots of us winning the rounds, but I forgot to...
I can't rewind.
You're using Toad as your...
Yeah, what do you think?
Do you like it?
It's cute.
Toad is here.
Hey, stay on my stream for a second.
Hey, Donkey fans.
Hey, come over here and drop that rhyme, huh?
Wait, Coney doesn't have past broadcasts.
How the fuck am I gonna...
Coney, you don't have...
Oh yeah, I don't have broadcasts on because I dox myself a lot.
God damn it.
We forgot to take screenshots, but we...
Oh no, just take screenshots of the...
Yeah, we're supposed to just take screenshots.
I don't have rewind on my stream.
I'll just say that.
Do you want me to...
I can put the screenshot in here.
Oh, you have it?
Wait, okay.
It's of the history here.
Oh, okay.
Okay, here we go.
We have...
Okay, that...
You are so smart.
I'm so...
I think my tired brain is like nuts.
We have this.
I'm gonna send these two just to make sure.
That's probably more comprehensive, yeah.
Let's use those.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll just use these.
All right, you guys are so much smarter.
I think it's because my brain is way too tired.
I was like, wait, I have...
I can look at my history.
There's no way to track history unless someone's streaming.
What the fuck?
I'm not okay right now.
Tony, whenever I think of Toad, I just think of this tweet.
Hold on.
Click that real quick and just read everything.
Oh boy.
Wait, what is this tweet?
Are you a participant of that?
No, I'm the green one, by the way.
Oh, yeah, yeah, sure.
Oh, you're not the purple one?
No, I'm not the purple one.
I'm the green one.
I love my fellow Toads, and that's as far as it goes.
Okay.
What?
What, you don't like the purple Toad?
I just noticed the purple one.
What's wrong with the purple Toad?
What's wrong?
Are you judging him?
Are you shaming the purple Toad?
I'm not going to stand for purple slander in here.
Did you even read the tweet, Beto?
Beto, did you even read the tweet?
Read each dialogue for us on stream.
Yeah, read it.
It's in the Rocket Raccoon.
Yeah.
Oh, I thought we were just talking about Toad colors.
No, no, no, read the tweet, Beto.
Read the tweet.
Oh, thank God I did it just about the first time.
Purple what?
That's not purple.
That's a Zark.
Oh, no, we all acknowledge it was purple.
It's a purple that just says, me too.
No, no, read more, read more, read more.
Read more, read more.
I'm not reading these.
No, read it.
Read it, come on.
You're just so curious.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with the purple?
I thought you loved purple, Beto.
I gotta lose Nintendo perms, I can't.
Oh, so you don't love purple.
I do love purple.
You don't love purple.
Purple's my favorite color, just not in this context.
So you're shaming him.
Shaming the purple Toad.
I tried vouching, I'm backing out.
Not loyal.
He's not loyal.
I'm gonna make gamer subs real quick, guys, I'll be right back.
Okay.
Do I leave?
I'm so ready to leave.
You just don't want to be here anymore.
I'm ready to go.
Wait, can we know when we get to play?
I think we added.
I have no idea, is it like when the next team's done?
How do we know when the next team's done?
That we fight?
I don't know, this is gonna cause complications if it's not starting by the time that was scheduled.
Ah, I see.
So it should have started already?
Yeah, okay.
Let me check first.
Yeah, check with them, check with them.
Because we're kind of running late right now, right?
Yeah, because we have to remake.
Oh, the remake was what did it, right?
I forgot.
Okay, we're supposed to start...
No, okay, we're on schedule.
Oh, we're on schedule?
Okay.
Ten minutes.
Ten minutes, we start the next one.
I think they baked in time, because there's gonna be stuff like this a lot, I think.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so there's four matches.
Hmm, okay, okay.
Oh, five matches.
Yeah.
Yeah, we play every other person in our group.
Ten minute losers' round.
Oh, okay, so that's if we're losers.
Yeah, I think if we're not in the losers' round, then we finish at like three-ish.
That sounds terrible.
I need us to finish at three, by the way.
Okay, what if we lose, though?
Then my team will be pissed at me, because I'm in a tournament right after this.
I'm back.
We definitely finished our games.
We finished our games way too fast.
We're the only team that finished both our matches.
Did we?
Yeah, I'm looking at the challenge.
We're the only ones that reported 2-0.
Our match was kind of fast, yeah.
Oh, wait, no, one team already finished.
Oh, okay.
So, okay, so the team that I said that I felt was like the hardest team also just finished their two matches.
Okay, good.
So, like, are they the only ones?
Round one, match two, okay.
So, Kultus, Oni...
Oh, yeah, Kultus and Oni.
Are what seem to be like the hard ones.
Because they both finished it.
The Oni inmates are the ones with the Venom and Spider.
Spider mains.
They also have a Wolverine player.
Let me wolf against them.
Let's see, I looked at what game they won.
The game they won, they went Cloak, Luna, Moon Knight, Magic.
Oh, so they have a Magic player.
I think that's their...
Yeah, Magic.
Oh, no, this is the wrong one.
This is the Maidens.
Okay, let me look at the Oni.
Okay, they went Wolverine, Rocket, Luna, Bucky, Punisher, Groot.
In their second round, they went Hawk.
I think in the second round, they just fucked around.
Because it's like Thor...
Yeah, it's Thor, Captain America, Storm, Hawkeye.
So I think in the second round, they just fucked around.
Because that's a weird lineup.
Oh, Boger is casting the tournament?
Yeah, he is casting.
Oh.
Holy, I didn't know that.
Guys, if we win the tournament, we get...
What was it?
$200 worth of Marvel Rival skins to you guys.
Whoa.
We don't have to spend money on skins ever again.
I already got a lot from the... Was it the other tourney?
Oh, yeah, the Toast one.
Yeah, the Toast one.
For second place.
What did you get for it?
For second place, the winners got all the skins that they wanted, right?
Yeah.
I think second place got just a bunch of blue creds.
How much credits did you get?
I don't... I think it was like $10,000 or something.
That's a lot.
It was a good amount, so I was happy with it.
This one is like... Whoa, shit, sorry.
This one is like $24,000.
We were kind of joking about consolation prize, but they actually did.
Oh, that's nice of them.
I'm still not over Nekros trolling and grabbing me and Sykkuno for his team.
I don't know what that was.
I mean, it was for content.
It was for content.
Because Volker got... What was it?
He got Jon and Dany.
Yeah, he got Jon on Thor, and then you're like, what the fuck did you do again?
Against Jon's Thor.
Literally, the only thing I could do against Jon's Thor was just freezing him 24-7.
His Thor is actually insane.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Flanking Thor when they know how to do it is scary.
Especially in randomized teams too, because you don't have enough time to coordinate yourself with your team to fucking...
Dude, are we talking about the toast tournament?
Yeah, yeah, when Jon was on Thor.
It pissed me off.
I had to win one more game.
I was on your team, Kony.
No, no, no.
Even before that, I'm in the last game, right?
In the last game, I had to win one more round, and then they target banned Fantastic.
I could not believe it.
I got fucking target banned, so I didn't get to the finals.
Lost all my skins to Skara.
Of course Skara would.
Yeah, Skara played Penny Parker.
So sad.
Next time I'm playing Thing.
It's just way easier.
Yeah, you just hold right click, and then...
Oh, fuck.
It's clobbering time.
Do I let Jay back in?
Huh?
I mean, we can, yeah.
Since he's going next, he needs to rally his mind.
Yeah, go for it.
Yeah, go for it if you want to.
Oh, you should figure out which streamer you're going to watch, Beto.
I'll put up all three at once.
All three at once?
Damn.
Damn, how many monitors does he have?
I have two, and one barely works.
I hope it's not the one where you're playing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm checking.
Alright, bye-bye.
Okay, bye-bye.
Heck no!
Put him away.
I'm like waiting for... they haven't updated round two, so I have no idea who we're facing next.
Welcome back, Jay.
Oh, hello.
Hi, Jay.
Hello.
I'm just trying to go check on my rats in the meantime.
Yeah, big rat.
I think big rat's my favorite.
How are we supposed to select the next one?
Funny, that's the one that likes me the most.
He's the one who keeps nibbling my fingers and trying to bite me.
I mean, that's the best name, though.
Big rat?
Yeah, I love that guy.
Big rat.
That's the only name I remember from all your rats.
It's the most memorable.
Big rat.
Doki, can you check DMs?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, check DMs.
Nice.
Oh, boy.
Actually, not nice, because that means we might have to face the really hard team.
And I hate playing that comp.
Nah, we got it.
We can't say what comp it is.
We can't say it.
What if we get stream sniped?
It's gonna happen.
No, they're gonna stream snipe for day two.
They will.
100%.
But if we do face that team, then they already know what comp we're gonna play.
I don't think they know how to play against it yet.
Are you talking about the comp I'm thinking that you're talking about?
Yeah, the comp that when we figured it out, we fucking...
Oh, that one.
The secret comp.
Our emergency comp when nothing works.
Yeah, when nothing works, we pull out the most cheap comp ever.
But we can't say it because they might research us for day two.
If we make it, we'll make it.
I hope we make it to day two.
Oh, I'm refreshing.
We didn't even update our scores.
Oh, no, they did.
Never mind.
There's still two more teams that are still fighting each other.
So we're waiting for that.
All right, chat.
I muted myself, guys, so I can talk to you guys.
I'm nervous.
That's the reason why I didn't sleep that much.
I literally couldn't go to sleep.
Last night...
Last night, I like...
Like, not warmed up, but practiced just to make sure that I was doing okay.
And then I lost a lot of games in Celestial.
On my alt account, I lost like...
Like, I have a Celestial account, like a Celestial alt account.
And then I lost a lot of games.
And I was like, isn't me?
And I was getting Luna banned too.
I was getting like Luna...
No, my main is one above all, guys.
You can literally see one above all right there.
No, I wasn't tilting because I didn't care about the SR on that account.
It was really used for practice.
And then I lost a lot.
And I was so sad because I was like, isn't me?
Am I bad at video games?
Am I washed already?
I was so... I was like freaking out.
So then I was got really nervous because like, I was just like, oh my god, I don't want to do bad tomorrow.
So then I like literally like I was in bed, in bed, and I couldn't fall asleep.
I just like try to... I was in bed trying to sleep for like five hours and I couldn't.
And then I finally went to like I finally fell asleep at 6 a.m.
I fell asleep at like 6 a.m.
And and then I like the one way to make me fall asleep was that because I was putting videos and stuff and everything.
I still couldn't sleep.
And one thing that actually got me to fall asleep was that I put on the newest games.
I just look at my recommend.
I just put a random long video in my YouTube recommended.
And my YouTube recommended recommended me a Minecraft game theory video about the tree lore or whatever the fuck.
I don't remember anything from that video.
It was like, I don't know.
Apparently they had a tree.
They had tree monsters in Minecraft.
And then I... and then I was... I was so...
We're watching which team?
I don't think... does every group have to be finished?
Or is it just our group?
Every group has to be... they haven't... because they haven't posted who we're fighting next.
So every group has to be finished.
Okay.
So yeah.
We just have to wait until...
Because they didn't... they need to wait for all groups to be finished to do a round 2.
Because we don't know who we're facing next.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah, that was basically... that was basically how I fell asleep.
And then, when I woke up, I wasn't groggy or tired at all.
I don't know, but it's an even fight.
Yeah, it seems like they're getting like...
Wait, who?
Are you watching?
They're gonna run for their money.
Mace.
Oh, Mace?
Okay, let me look.
I mean, I can look up the team list right now.
That's surprising.
I thought Mace's team would do really well because of the individual players.
Oh, they're just focus banning Mace.
That's why.
Oh!
I mean, that was our plan too, so...
And we had to fight.
Is that just like a Mag-Strange ban?
Yeah, yeah.
I think they protected Mag.
Gotcha.
Oh, then he has... but he's like...
He can play Mag.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, let me look at his team.
Well, little do people know, his Mag's better than his Strange.
So...
Wait.
We'll keep that info.
Wait, I'll show you who they're facing.
And I'm just like...
Okay.
Let me see if I can...
This is the right one.
Let me see.
Okay, this is...
I know like... I can kind of see the ELO for each team.
The average ELO.
So I'm like, surprised.
Alright, this is their ELO.
Average.
I posted in Team Rocket Raccoon.
Oh, that is so small.
Yeah, but you gotta click on it.
And you can see.
That's why I'm like...
I can't read it.
Just click on the image!
I am!
It's so small!
Click on the image!
And just click zoom in!
Yeah, and then the top right, there's a zoom in.
Okay, I got it.
So, these are who we're against, right?
These are the people that...
This is the people Mace is against.
Oh...
So I think we're fighting that other team.
We might be fighting the other team in finals.
If we make it to finals.
Gosh, she's so hyped right now.
No, that team is hard.
I'm gonna invite y'all, by the way.
Already in the lobby.
Did you leave the lobby?
I'm already in here.
I'm in here.
We don't have...
Who else?
We don't have Cody.
Cody, get in here!
Leave me!
The next map is...
Royal Palace Domination.
Palace?
Is that the...
Asgard or whatever?
That's the Koth map.
The Koth map with...
Yeah, the Koth map with the chandelier.
That's the one.
Big ass one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm refreshing and we still don't have round 2.
I'm gonna get a drink.
I'll be right back.
To my chat, I hope everybody's VC is good now.
I muted myself too.
I don't even remember what I was talking about.
Oh yeah.
Tournaments always make me really nervous.
This tournament makes me really nervous.
Because it's my first real Marble Rivals tournament.
So I was like...
I'm very nervous right now.
I'm like actually like...
Super nervous.
And like...
Scared.
Because it's my first Marble Rivals tournament.
And we actually scrimmed as a team.
You guys might not know this.
But we actually scrimmed a lot as a team.
And I really appreciate everybody giving up their time for it.
Because I organized all the scrims and stuff.
And I requested hard teams too.
In this tournament to play against.
So the hardest team.
The hardest team that we believe that's in this tournament.
We actually scrimmed them twice already.
And that's why when I was talking to my team.
I was like, I'm scared of that team.
Because they actually were really good.
So we like...
We figured out how to beat them.
But then like...
Because the first scrim, they beat us.
Because they target banned Betel.
But then like obviously...
Because it was our very first scrim together too.
It was our very very first scrim together.
But then Betel can't be target banned anymore.
Because he learned other characters.
So he's okay now.
But because it was our first scrim.
So we learned what to do after that.
It was a huge learning experience.
Because we were winning.
And then when they figured it out.
They were like, okay.
Now you can play other characters.
So we're fine now.
So it's okay.
But then after they figured us out in the first scrim.
They beat us in the first scrim.
And in the second scrim.
In the second scrim against them.
We beat them.
But we had to like...
Analyze that team.
We actually researched that team to figure out.
Because we believe they are the hardest team in the pyramid.
We believe they are the hardest team.
We didn't stream their last scrim too by the way.
We didn't stream that scrim.
Just because it would be a lot of intel.
It's like...
It always goes longer than it's supposed to.
Just because of admin issues.
Yeah.
We actually did like...
I think we did 5 scrims together as a team.
I'm pretty sure.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Or 4.
I think it was like 4 to 5 scrims together as a team.
At one point we had a double block.
So we scrimmed together as a team.
For 4 hours straight.
With like 2 different teams.
So...
We wanted to make sure we bonded as a team.
And that we know what the fuck we're doing together.
So like...
That's why I'm nervous.
Because I'm really appreciative.
All of us took this very seriously.
And we actually took the competitive of it very seriously.
And we were actually analyzing.
And figuring out what's our best comps.
And everything.
And making sure our weaker points are...
Like...
Limeu learned Adam.
Within 2 weeks.
Which is crazy.
Her Adam is fucking insane now.
Because she never played Adam before.
And now she's like an insane Adam player.
Because like...
We decided to have...
We decided to...
We thought Adam was really good for this new meta.
So she actually learned Adam in 2 weeks.
And I gave her notes about how to play as a support and everything.
So like...
All of us were like...
Figuring out stuff together.
And figuring out what characters we each have to learn.
And what our weakest points were.
And that's why...
And then we like...
Beto got coached by Hogs.
We got Hogs in to coach Beto too.
So that he wasn't...
He could play other tanks as well.
So yeah.
That's why I'm nervous.
I was so nervous about this tournament.
Because it's our first real tournament.
And I was like...
I was so nervous.
So that's why I couldn't...
That's why I hope that...
Because I didn't sleep that much today.
I'll be able to sleep earlier.
I didn't sleep that much yesterday.
So today I'll be able to sleep more.
Because I'd be really tired for staying up.
So I'm just hoping for that right now.
I hope so.
I hope we make it today too.
I really do.
I just really enjoy...
If we win all of our games today.
I'm going to buy...
Roasted duck.
No mercy.
That means no mercy for all our teams going in.
If we lose even one game, I get no duck.
Okay.
We're locking it in bro.
We got the team now.
We got to add the caster too.
I'll give you the UID.
Add the caster and this one.
I'll research them right now real quick.
I'll do it.
I can literally pull up...
Because they won their last game.
They're the magic player by the way.
They have the magic player.
So we just ban magic.
Yeah.
And they run strange mag.
And they have a moon knight player too.
We want to ban moon knight.
So that's the main thing to look out for.
Magic, strange, moon knight.
They run strange mag.
That's their tank lineup.
We can ban...
If they can't play magic, they play storm.
We just ban magic.
Magic we don't want to deal with anyway.
Or ban both magic and storm.
Just say fuck that guy in particular.
Yeah sure, fuck that guy.
I think we should ban magic first.
Yeah, agree.
But they might keep storm safe after that.
Then we just gotta figure out what to do.
They have so many casters.
What if we just sneak Betel in as a caster?
I feel like I've seen more casters than teammates.
Or like opponents.
I've been just pining for my casters.
I was like, oh, Bogr is casting for this?
I thought you said Betel.
Because both their names start with B.
Sorry guys.
We're ready whenever, right?
Or do we have to wait?
Let us know when our...
Alright, the gamer stuff is kicking in.
Who's their scariest player?
I mean, the Celestial one is a support player.
Okay.
They're all a hidden profile.
Oh wait, except for...
No, they're all hidden profiles, so you can't see.
Everybody's taking it very seriously.
Alright, who in my team did not hide their profiles?
Oh, I blocked you.
Sorry, I blocked Gomez.
Okay, Chodo.
They'll just think you're a low-key player.
Okay, Kony.
They'll definitely think you're our thing player.
Wait, none of us hid our profiles?
Except for me and Night?
My shit is hidden.
It's friend only.
Oh, friends only.
Okay, that's alright.
That would be so awkward.
We're good.
I'll put everything on friends only now.
Okay, I was gonna be like, Guys!
That would have been so awkward.
It's FanKing, Marcins, and Cassie.
Mine's not private, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You and I were the only ones that were fully private.
We don't even want friends to know.
I don't want my friends to judge me.
I don't want my friends to know my stats.
We're ready to.
Yeah, let's do it.
Alright, where's Jay?
Oh, wait, Jay's not...
I'm here, I'm here.
Alright, nice.
Okay, everything's good.
Alright.
Yay, alright.
Let's get it.
There's professionals, don't worry.
Alright, I'm gonna be...
I was gonna be interested to see what they target Ben.
Alright, let's see.
Who are they gonna target Ben?
Gomez?
Oh, they are.
Alright, well.
No one wants to play your star though.
Just get Magic out.
Alright.
Ben, Magic.
And then we keep...
Luna safe.
I guess we just keep Luna safe, yeah.
I love not being able to play that character.
I mean, you literally played it last game.
What are you talking about?
You don't even get to play your character in your real scrims.
I know.
Oh, there it is.
Of course.
Alright.
What's our second ban?
I guess we just ban Moon Knight.
The other player plays Moon Knight.
You know what?
What?
Do I pull out the fist again?
I could bring out the Fist of Cuffs.
Yeah, good team up with Luna.
Oh, yeah.
They looked at Coney's list.
They actually looked at Coney's thing.
Wow.
Coney, that's why you should have private.
You sold, bro.
You sold us out.
Oh, wait.
Do we pull out the three comp against them?
What's the three comp?
Hey, you want Mag or Strange?
I'll play the other one.
I'll play Garutes.
Oh, 3-3-3?
I'll play 3-3-3.
3-3-3?
Let's see how it goes.
Let's see it.
Let's bring out Goats.
Oh, we're doing this?
Yeah.
Was I on Mantis or Luna?
I forgot.
I think Luna for now.
Yeah, we need Luna for the heal.
The defensive.
I thought this only worked because I had Thing for damage, but maybe Mag has damage.
Wait, you said they have a Wolverine player?
No, not this team.
They might play Wolverine.
If they play the Wolverine, we just fucking swap comps instantly.
I go back to Namor.
This doesn't work.
I think I can swap and just go...
The only issue is that the Storm might farm ult really fast on us.
Oh yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Who's gonna kill the Storm, guys?
I can kill her.
I think we just do this then.
Okay, so 2-1-3?
That works okay.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, who the fuck is killing the Storm?
I think if they play any high mobility characters, then yeah, we can pull it out.
Okay, we'll adjust.
We'll adjust.
Are they portal?
Right side.
Break the top.
Break the buildings.
Yep.
Storm is one.
Storm is dead.
Nice.
They're gonna split up, no?
Yeah, I'm pushing up.
Oh my god, nice.
That's right.
What is the Storm gonna do for you?
Oh my goodness.
I think...
I don't know about that portal.
I threw away so much pressure.
Yeah, I need heals.
You guys can heal me real quick.
Sorry.
I'll get hit.
I'm gonna farm some portals.
Nah, you don't need to farm some portals.
It's not like that urgent.
They're split.
Yeah, I see them.
They have Hella.
I'm pulling someone in.
Okay, did you do it?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Holy shit.
Storm low?
No, no, no.
We're getting kinda low though, yeah.
Actually.
Oh,
we're getting sniped right now.
I'm going for Storm.
I'm going too far.
I got you, I got you.
Don't be rushed.
Yeah, we can't do it for a show.
Don't stuck.
I want...
Okay, we have copy.
Copy, copy, copy.
Copy, please.
I'm blocking it, I'm blocking it.
We have two shields.
3, 2, 1.
We lost this.
Okay, it's done, it's done, it's done.
I'm gonna freeze it.
You're missing Luna.
I'm coming back.
I'm not gonna use my ult then.
Can I try?
I got you, I got you.
Again, again, again.
Again.
One more.
Just one more, bro.
Come on, just one more.
One more again, I need it.
Dude, my bad on the ult.
That didn't look like Doctor... My chat is flaming me for the idea.
That did not look like Doctor Strange, bro!
I threw it at Cloak, but Strange was standing in front of her and I was like, alright, I'll kill Cloak.
But then he shielded it and I was like, oh, that's Doctor Strange.
I thought it was like Moon Knight.
The skin was weird, man.
I thought I was gonna let Doki ult first because I thought that's what we agreed on.
No, no, I didn't have mine yet.
I didn't have it.
That's why I was like, oh, copy, copy, copy.
Yeah, I just shifted and then did it.
I was like, oh, damn.
I was like, SHUT UP!
It was on me!
I know, I know, I know.
It was on me, I was so scared.
That was actually an ult plan.
A second ult.
And we milked it, that was part of the value.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's called limit testing, guys.
Limit testing, yeah.
Dive for the cause.
I got Strange ult.
Can look for something.
Yeah, we should engage with your ult first.
And then we'll see how it goes.
So, we can just walk in with Link.
Just be really aggressive.
Yeah.
I can just WQ here.
Okay, let's just look for ults here, yeah?
Can I look for something?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, just shoot it.
Can't bubble anymore.
We can't look for a big ult here, okay?
We can burn that, burn it, burn it.
Burn ult, burn ult.
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm pulling him in.
It's fine.
We can rez it if you want.
It's too far out, too far out.
No!
Oh no!
We weren't close enough to the body.
Yeah.
Maybe they're feeling scared about it.
Okay, we got value, we got value.
Oh my god, now you value.
Oh no.
I'm getting hit by Shrays.
I pulled him in.
Oh shit.
Is that soloing or no?
Oh, that's not fine.
No, we didn't have the time.
Reset, reset.
I'm grouping up, grouping up.
I have portal, actually.
Can we look for something?
I'm good for portal, yeah.
We're too far up to portal.
Okay.
Let's go left side.
We portal.
We portal for like touch or any other point.
I'm just saving that, I'm saving it.
We might have to swap up out of them for more heals here.
After this.
Yeah, I'm pushing up, yeah.
Oh fuck.
We have copy, we have copy.
Copy, copy.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Everyone was like on top of Doki, I could not see.
That's fine, that's fine.
We're still up one, we're still up one.
Yeah.
Okay, it's done, it's done, it's done.
I'm gonna freeze.
Okay.
Got it.
I got Agamotto'd.
This is winnable.
Do you want me to switch to Sue?
Yeah, swap to Sue.
I don't think we can get the TP on.
Can we?
No.
We can, we can, we can.
I'll ult him.
I have to jump in immediately right now.
I'm blocking, I'm blocking.
I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
I'm burning that.
I can block it, I can block it, I can block it.
I'm going in now, I'm going in now.
You ready?
3, 2, 1.
Big ult here.
Big, big, big.
3, 2, 1.
I need shields.
Oh shit.
I didn't have it.
We have Sue ult, we have Sue ult here.
I'm being chased, I'm being chased.
I'm being chased really hard.
On their backline.
Oh nice, nice, nice.
Big pull, big pull.
Massive, massive, massive.
Good shit.
On the left, on the left, on the left.
I'm always waiting.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Back, back, back.
What ult do we have here?
We got Sue ult.
We got mag ult soon.
We just play for Sue ult.
Whenever they come in with a...
Careful left, careful left.
Hold top, hold top by me.
You're by yourself, Gomez, you're by yourself.
He's fine, he's fine.
They're coming from top high ground.
Over here, over here, over here on me.
Oh fuck me.
There's bubble though, there's bubble.
I need some help here, I need some help.
I need help.
I'm with you, I'm literally with you.
Again?
There's Storm ult.
The Storm is right here.
We have Sue ult for Storm ult.
When you see the Sue, you just ult yours.
Yeah, don't push up.
It's one more push.
One more fight, one more fight.
They have Strange ult, they have Strange ult too.
Yeah, I have Strange ult though.
I have Counter Strange ult.
We're over here.
They're not all in.
Shoot through the port, shoot through the port.
Kill them for a big ult here, okay?
Oh my god, he's so close.
Yeah, he's so low, bro.
We have ult here.
Okay, they counted?
Yeah.
Don't do anything, we're fine.
I pulled the DPS in, pulled them in.
Are we concealed now?
Yeah, we need it.
I got frozen, I got frozen.
I got frozen.
Oh, unlucky.
As I was doing it, I got frozen.
Yeah, no hesitation there.
Yeah, you gotta go for it immediately.
Because I needed to copy it.
After.
Alright.
I was doing it and I got frozen.
I was about to take it too, but I didn't know.
If you were waiting until the last second.
That's alright, we got ult.
I'm not sure if that was even targeted on me intentionally.
No, he was doing it for all...
We were all grouped up to support.
So he was targeting the supports intentionally.
They don't have TP, we don't have TP.
We just walk up.
I'm gonna put the snowflake on you.
So you won't be more aggressive.
I might swap to the tank still.
If they get low.
We go lowkey ult first here.
I have mine.
I'll ult after lowkey.
So you don't have to...
Actually no, I'll do strange ult.
So you can do the other defensive ult.
Yeah, Doki, you have...
Oh my god.
Doki, you just be reactive for strange ult.
Yeah, I do strange.
I was literally like 3% from strange.
I could have done it if I had it.
Is it okay if I use strange ult to trade supports?
Is that not okay?
No, it's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, cause then Gormus gets a free ult.
Okay, I'll call for it always.
I'm dropping down.
I'm bouncing it.
Am I dropping down?
I have no idea.
I'm dropping down.
I'm gonna try to look for a pull.
Yeah, yeah.
No shift, no shift.
Yeah, no shift.
No runes, no runes.
No shift.
Okay, are we walking with ult?
Yeah.
I'm gonna use, I'm using, I'm using.
Oh, sorry.
I thought I was going first.
I was waiting for yours, but I'm doing damage boost.
Oh, we're both dead, we're both dead.
You just...
Okay.
I got two, I got two.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
I'm swapping now.
We're soaking this point, we're soaking this point.
We can...
We can stay here.
I can go backline, you ready?
Go backline here with my ult.
I'm dying, I'm dying.
I'm pushing with you.
Yep, I need to get out.
I'm coming in with ult.
Fuck, I'm dead.
They don't have point, they don't have point.
They're low, they're low, they're low.
We can't anymore, they got point now.
We got a pick.
We got one pick.
You can't push up.
Sorry, there was like hesitation, so then I went for mine.
Because I didn't know if you were going to do it.
I was, I did it a little too late though.
Yeah, yeah.
If you hesitate, I would ult.
I wasn't sure, because Coney died so fast.
I was like, oh fuck, well, okay, I don't know what to do now.
Yeah, I got Namor ulted.
Can we jump now?
I'm pushing up.
Good job, yeah.
I have ult up, I'm ready to do it, but I'm waiting for theirs.
Looking for pull, looking for pull.
I pulled into Luna, Luna one.
Oh, Luna one.
I'm up, I'm up, I'm up, I'm up.
Got her.
Namor no shift.
I react on Strange ult.
Loki down, Loki down.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god, nice.
I'm looking at Namor.
We got point.
We should push up.
We need to push up, we need to push up.
Alright, alright.
I have ult.
I react to Strange, I react to Strange.
Looking for a pull.
I'm looking for a pull right now.
Let them walk in a little bit.
I have ult, I have ult too.
Are they going under?
They might go under.
I see them going under.
Let's go, let's go.
I have squirrels.
That's a really good ult.
I have Strange ult.
I can look for a big ult.
I can look for a big ult here.
I'm looking for it, I'm looking for it.
I got you, I got you.
Just hold it, just hold it.
Yeah, just hold it, I'm holding it.
Yeah, I'm holding it.
Hold in this range.
Nevermind, I guess the game didn't want me.
Dude, they're like cut off, they don't know what to do here.
Oh my god, this is good.
They're wasting their time.
Look at Strange, look at Strange.
I need shields, I need shields, I need shields.
I'm going back to point.
I'm going to point.
I'm on the point.
I'm just holding.
But she's not doing anything.
Oh, she died, there we go.
Someone's here, I think I see someone there.
We have no ults though.
I got ult too, but...
They used Strange, they used Mag.
They have name all up.
Let's push up a little bit, make them go under again.
Oh wait, they might TP.
They're on point, they're on point.
Looking for vault, looking for vault.
I'm going to cut off, I'm going to try to get around to you guys.
I vaulted one, but I'm looking for vault.
I'm dying, I'm dying, I need heals.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I have TP, I have TP, I have Strange TP.
We got the vault.
Just fight, just fight, just stay in.
And then we TP in, we TP in.
Yeah, I'm porting in, I'm porting in, I'm porting in.
They're going to try and stagger me, I'm running.
Are you in this, are you in this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, she is, she is.
I'm dropping on high ground, I'm porting on high ground, I'm porting on high ground.
Alright, I forced Luna ult, I guess?
Yeah, yeah, that's good, that's good.
I'm dropping down, I'm dropping down.
I got stunned by Skrugle.
Good shield.
I'm going for Skrugle, okay?
Skrugle one, Skrugle one, Skrugle one.
Strange is one.
I'm looking at Strange right now.
I can kill him, I can kill him.
Skrugle kind of low, Skrugle kind of low.
He's low, he's low, I got Strange, Strange dead.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Kill me, kill me, kill me, kill me.
Got you, got you.
I'm on Skrugle, I'm on Skrugle.
Skrugle, Skrugle, Skrugle, Skrugle, Skrugle.
Skrugle's dead, I got Skrugle.
I'm on Luna, Luna.
I'm on her, I'm on her.
Luna's low, Luna's so low.
Luna's one, Luna's one.
She's coming from far under.
Good job, good job, good job.
Cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
Where the fuck is...
What the fuck?
Guys, guys, focus, focus.
No, the shield didn't work.
We have shield as well, we have shield as well.
I'm blocking, I'm blocking still.
I have ult soon as well, okay?
I have ult soon as well.
They should have...
Their team's back, their team's back.
I have to look for something.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Oh my god, bro.
Holy shit.
That's huge!
That's the boys!
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
That was a good play.
Good play there, good play.
Okay, we shouldn't run 3v3 against this team.
I don't think we should run triple support against this team.
Oh my god, bro.
I was eyeing my fucking ult so fucking hard, bro.
Jesus Christ.
That was a good ult, bro.
That was good.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we comboed it so well.
Yeah.
Do we put Bettle in round 2?
I don't know.
Do we put Bettle?
We can put Bettle.
We'll put Bettle in round 2.
I don't know, because if they ban Thing again, I'm way more comfortable on Mag than I am on Strange.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean, I'm okay.
I'm not trying to say what we should do, but if he's more comfortable on Mag...
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah.
What do you mean a Mag player?
What's your guys' call?
I think we should keep Liss then, because this is a harder team.
Just because if they target Bettle, we might be fucked.
If I get a Thing ban, then I have to be on Mag.
Or Strange, but I'm worse on Strange.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay, guys.
I'll grab the screenshot off my profile.
Alright.
Alright, we'll just tell Bettle, like, this team might target ban you, so...
Actually, it might be better.
Wait, might target ban you, so...
No,
we've seen the Bettle-Strange.
Right?
Should we?
Bettle-Strange is not that bad.
Bettle-Strange?
Oh, so should we get Bettle in here?
He's been practicing a lot.
I played with him yesterday.
He's really good.
Nevermind, you get in here.
Yeah, that was a huge I.
He left.
Unlucky.
Alright, I'll get Bettle in.
Where's Bettle?
Invite.
Wait, what?
He's not online.
I think he's away because he's spectating.
He was spectating and stuff.
All that and then just left.
He's like, okay, and then bye.
Welcome back.
I'm out.
I'm in.
What's happening?
Wait, did you not watch?
I was watching.
That was intense.
It got intense.
That Namor ult at the end was fucking crazy.
I wish I was able to see it.
It was a little messy.
Sorry on my end for the double support ult.
No, me too.
I fucked up as well.
I think we all fucked up a little bit.
Even that small shit just adds up so much and it's so scary.
I don't think with this team we don't run triple support against this team.
I think you on a DPS shadow was more value for us.
I think the only time we're going to run that 3-3 is against that one team that we were scrimming against a lot.
No, we're not.
No, no, no.
We're totally not doing that, guys.
Yeah, we're totally not doing that.
Oh, they're ready, by the way.
They're ready.
I'm ready.
I'm going to put the screenshot.
They're good.
Let's go.
Huge, huge, huge.
Yeah, that was to the wire.
Yeah, that was close.
Yeah, I got a little too close.
Let's see if they first ban me or not.
Should we even protect Mag?
You got glazed, by the way, Bettle.
I'm hearing your strange is really good right now.
Oh, yeah?
Who said that?
Yeah, I said that.
Limu, Shoto, and Coney.
Yeah, but the practice, yeah.
Yeah, you've been practicing hard.
You got coached, too.
Oh, yeah, let's just protect Mag.
Wouldn't it be smarter to protect Thing so that Coney can play the Thing?
That's true.
I'm good with either.
Who was our main ban last time, guys?
It was Magic.
Magic?
Okay.
You wanna be our I guy?
You wanna be I of Agamotto?
I'm good to save Thing or Mag.
Your guy's cool.
Let's just save the Thing.
I'm down for that.
I'm making the call.
At least Bettle can play strange if they ban I.
Oh, they might do Groot combo.
So we should just ban Groot.
I'm banning Groot then.
I think because we banned...
Oh, ban Luna.
We get Mag and Thing.
This is great.
Yeah, Mag and Thing is great.
I don't like the combo.
I don't know if we... This team does a lot of damage.
I don't know if we should run Adam Su.
Do we run Adam Su?
I don't know.
We don't have to.
I'll run Loki's.
We could do this too still, right?
I don't think we should because I think Eon DPS was a lot more value for us.
Okay, I can do this then.
I'll run...
Gomez, get the fuck off Loki right now.
I like playing Loki though.
Get the fuck off Loki.
Hey, Loki doesn't work on Swap to Cloak.
Oh, it's this map.
I said help.
Oh, we're helping Master Reaver.
I knew that.
I mean, if I play safe, I could go Cloak.
Moon Knight kind of gets fucked by Sightlock 24x7.
Oh yeah, you could do that and I do Bucky.
I'll just play safe.
My Loki's not that great.
I like it.
So I don't have to aim at these.
Yeah, wait, you just countered their Moon Knight since they're always going to be doing Tri Moon Knight stuff then I think because that's why they saved it, right?
Yeah, that was their intention to do the combo.
So what's the point of playing?
Oh yeah, if they do Moon Knight, then I shouldn't be playing Loki.
Line for this one, you ult first.
Okay.
I don't see a Moon Knight.
Oh, I also countered that.
Okay, nice.
That's perfect.
Oh wait, we have Bucky.
Dude, this is so good for us.
I'm waiting for him to walk in a little bit.
Yeah, I don't really have an angle on this area until they push up.
Oh, I almost pulled the punch there.
Push her down.
Someone on top, on the roof, on the roof, on me.
Come here, come here, come here.
Oh no, I need you.
Oh, sorry.
I had to get on the site because he was on me first.
Yeah, I put my bubble on you.
But like, I died for it.
I'm going for a kill.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
If you're getting targeted, just walk to me.
And then I just say, Moon Knight on you, and I'll push up bubble.
Just stand in front of me, stand in front of me.
I don't think it was Moon Knight.
I don't know what it was.
Yeah, just stand in front of me.
Stand in front of me, stand in front of me.
Stand in front of me.
Still on the Punisher.
No, I'm coming back, I'm coming back right now.
Oh, they ulted.
Punisher's dead again.
Yep, ulting.
Nice.
I'm pulling Strange.
Oh, Mag, Mag can die too.
Nice, nice, nice.
Another one.
There's somebody here.
Got it.
Let's get it.
You and me, baby.
There we go.
They used Moon Knight ult, so they should have Strange and Magneto.
Yeah, they're low.
Okay, so they don't have support ult, and they don't have Moon Knight ult.
When I ult, keep your shield for me.
You got it, yeah.
I whiffed a kill.
I have ult soon.
They might go with Strange ult, so I have to make sure I don't get in.
They're letting this shit go back.
I might just look for picks.
Moon Knight's one.
Oh, I may have missed there.
Oh my god, that was a huge bubble.
Oh my god.
I'm pulling Strange.
Oh, fuck.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'll back up.
I'll be on me.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Oh, okay.
I shield you for the Agumon ult.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay for now, but Strange on me, nevermind.
Okay.
It's fine.
Fine.
I'm coming back with ult, I'm coming back with ult.
I should wear ult now.
Come on, Moon Knight.
I'm close to my ult.
I might be able to swap.
I'm going to swap to Strange and...
Actually no, I don't know how to fucking play.
I've never played Strange before.
I was going to say, I've never done the portal before.
It might not be a good idea.
We're going to have Lime ult soon.
Oh my god.
We have Lime ult soon.
Touch, touch, touch, touch, touch, touch.
Use your ult as soon as you get Lime.
Nice.
For their Moon Knight.
Yeah, he has ult.
He's going to look for a nasty one, so spread out a bit.
Thank you.
Another one.
I'm sitting on point.
Moon Knight.
Back up, just stay on point.
Stay on point.
We've got 20 seconds.
Don't go crazy.
They've got to get all the way around.
Right here, right here, right here, right here.
Strange, Strange.
I'm pulling Psylocke.
Break the runes.
Okay, okay, we're good, we're good.
Good shit.
I'm on...
Punching Mag.
I'm on Mag, I'm on Mag.
I'm trying to get the guy on top.
Hold on, I'm going after Dueler.
Dueler dead, Dueler dead.
Going after Loki.
Got it.
Just Mag, just Mag.
Nice.
Good shit.
I'm going to pull this guy.
We'll push him away.
Nice.
Good kill, good kill.
They can't.
Yeah.
Good shit.
Yay!
Wait, who... Bro.
I don't know.
It's one of the admins.
Who was it that came in and said, hey Doki, what the hell was that?
I think it was one of the mods.
We're in game.
Yeah, we're in game.
Oh, they want... Wait, what?
Somebody...
Oh, we were supposed to start on stream.
Well, we already started the game.
Game already...
Yeah, yeah.
Did we restart?
No, we already...
No, no, no, we already started the game.
Oh, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I forgot about stuff.
Whoops.
We were locked in, bro.
I'm sorry.
We're so locked in.
Yeah, we're like...
We're comming and they're like, Doki.
And I'm like...
Oh, I'm so excited right now.
Yeah.
I thought we had a new teammate.
I'm like, who the fuck was that?
Yeah.
Somebody just came in and said, hey Doki, like a fan?
Like, who is that?
That's what sticks out, a fan.
The server code leaked, they got in here.
Okay, well, I guess for the next one we have to make sure that they're spectating.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought they were already.
Yeah, I thought they were in there.
I guess they got kicked out.
I saw like three people in spectate.
I don't think production knows that they can just stay at the very end, select stream, and then just wait for the next game to start.
Oh, now they know.
Oh, they can just look at replay viewer.
Replay viewer is fine.
Yeah, yeah.
It's gonna be a little scuffed, but it'll work.
Oh, that's not cool.
I sort of got you there.
Yeah, I'm peeking a little bit.
I'm looking for a push here, looking for a pull.
I'm playing Mag.
Mag, Mag pull, Mag pull.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I don't have no dash, what am I doing?
Okay, nevermind.
I got away with it.
What are you doing?
Nevermind, I got away with it.
You died.
I got a kill though.
I got a kill.
One for one.
Yeah, we walk up, we walk up here.
I'm gonna look for another pull.
I'm playing Mag.
Oh, fuck.
He dodged.
Strange, strange low.
I'm gonna get some too.
Nice and easy.
We're just good against all of them.
Yeah, nice and easy.
Just walk it in.
Somebody get those.
Yep.
I can't.
I'm seeing a lot of homes.
Oh my god, he pulled me.
He's low HP.
He pulled me as soon as I dodged though.
That's so sad.
That's so lucky.
8 HP!
I'm so sad.
Oh no.
Okay.
Backing up.
That's my fault.
Yeah, back up, back up, back up.
He's too far up.
It's fine, it's fine.
We're about to get ults up.
I'll be there in a second.
I have ult here.
I can ult.
I ulted for it.
I pulled, I pulled many more.
Wait, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear, fear.
Pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Okay.
Nice.
It's fine, it's fine.
We got...
We got one pick.
We walk up with it, walk up with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm pulling, I'm pulling.
Thank you.
I don't have ult, please.
Okay, nice.
That's fine.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm blinded.
Look at this one.
They're in the back.
Magno, Magno.
Shit.
Actually, that's fine.
That's good, that's good.
Look at the ult, look at the ult.
Oh my god.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh, we don't have anything.
We have nothing for that.
Yeah, we got eye, too.
Eye, they're super dead.
We can...
Oh, that's insane.
I'm in the back line, beating the shit out of them, but no.
It's okay, we can... it's good.
Reset here.
I miscounted their ults.
I didn't know they had a heal ult there.
They have no support ults, though.
They have no support ults for you, Gomez.
Use both.
Use both?
Yeah, use both, use both.
Yeah, we got Bucky and Psylocke.
We should go...
Should we do Bucky first or Psylocke first?
I can do...
I can do first.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, you go first.
We'll wait for your pick.
Alright.
Got one.
Good.
Go for it, go for clones.
Yup.
Nice.
Reset.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm on mag, I'm on mag, I'm on mag.
Got the root again, though.
Got the reset, got the reset, got the reset.
Root again, though.
Wait, this guy is good.
Got reset, got another reset.
Oh, yeah.
No!
Wait, that's fine, we can do this, that's fine.
Where is she?
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Did Bettle DC it?
Yeah, he still won.
Oh, he DCs.
Oh, my goodness.
He was BMing, he knew we would win.
He BMed so hard.
Bro, that's crazy.
Dude, honestly, I thought someone on their team left or something, but then it was Bettle, I thought she was BMing.
We don't need a restart, guys.
We don't need a restart.
You got this, guys.
I'm gonna take five.
Alright, we're done with round two.
Round two is done.
Two more games, two more matches.
What's the next one?
Let me see.
Alright.
Let me just...
Let me screenshot this.
I think we just send the replay code, because we started without them.
Just rewatch it.
Welcome back.
Guys, my game crashed.
It's okay, we won.
It's okay.
We won.
I did a BM lead.
We thought you were BMing.
We thought you were like, yeah, you got this.
I'm done.
That won't happen again.
I have never had a game crash before.
That's crazy.
That's funny.
I'm gonna be right back.
I need to use bathroom too.
I'll be right back too.
Yep, me too.
One sec.
Alright.
I sent them the match code, so then...
They know what to do.
Dude, what are the...
Dude, that's crazy.
Yeah, you were...
We know you were just doing it on purpose.
I got critical error.
You did?
I got that too.
I got that too, one time.
Before I changed PCs.
Did you update your drivers?
My drivers have been...
Yeah, I did that like last week.
Okay, that's the problem.
The drivers...
No, what?
You have to roll back.
Yeah, you have to roll back.
I did it in preparation for this.
You gotta go back.
Go back one driver.
Yeah, this version of the drivers is unstable with mobile drivers.
I think like two more versions back, I think, was good for me.
Or three.
You have to check.
Oh, I'm on the patch before it.
It's working fine.
That's insane.
What's insane?
What happened?
So, if you update...
Yeah, so if you update your drivers to the most recent ones for NVIDIA...
It has some really bad crashing problems when it comes to the drivers.
Yeah, this is why I don't update until my PC dies.
Oh, you don't update your drivers?
I update my drivers every three to four months.
What?
Because you don't update right away.
That's the thing.
What?
Three to four months?
Yeah.
I mean, one time I didn't update my drivers for a year.
Actually, no, you're right.
You're right.
It's like, why would you update to the next Windows yet?
Yeah, you don't know.
I remember for Apex, you don't do it right away, so it was just habit.
Because in Apex, they had a thing where if you updated to a new driver, you'd lose frames or some shit.
And you had to use the specific driver, and then they fixed it, but then I didn't realize they fixed it.
So I used a year-old driver because I didn't realize they fixed the thing.
Oh.
Because it was like an Apex issue.
Jesus.
Alright.
That wasn't our hardest team, though.
That's the thing.
It wasn't?
Yeah.
I personally think...
That wasn't too bad.
Yeah.
No, you weren't there for the Domination one.
Domination one was a little too close, but I think we were just really messy, too.
We were super messy there.
That was our first match as well.
I feel like we were kind of warm and ready.
I think we were trying to figure out what comp to play against them, and now we know triple support doesn't work against that team.
I'm scared of the next team.
Come on, where is it?
I like it when we have triple support with Venom.
I think that works better, when we have Venom and triple support.
I agree.
I think so, too.
I think we definitely did a lot better with it.
We're still on the Duck Train, so that's good.
Still on the Duck Train.
We were the first team that finished, too, so our teams are still fighting.
Really?
I thought we won for a bit.
Actually, no, because we never passed that first point, so that makes sense.
I think it's just Domination has a set time, too.
Yeah.
You know what I was just thinking?
It's so funny, because Beto was talking about how it's hard to play strange ult, and it's very obvious when you're walking up, and it's hard to do.
And then every strange we've seen today, when they're about to ult, they just randomly aggro the person all the way in the back and walk through everybody on the team.
It's like their sleeper phrase was activated, and now they want to get right to the back.
It's so funny to watch.
Also, the classic Coney, the fly up in the air, and they just forget about you.
Yep, they disappear.
Where did the strange go?
He's not in front of me.
He's gone.
Marvel rival players have no object permanence.
No, every shooter player has no object permanence.
He must have died.
Did he go to heaven?
No, he raptured up to heaven.
That's what happened.
God called him back.
Yeah, God called him.
Gamers don't look up or down, they just look straight ahead.
It's true.
So next game is in what, five minutes?
Depending, well, whenever the team's finished, let me look at, let me scout out who's posted their results.
Yeah, Oni, the Oni image won.
They started erase, they started like...
They started, okay, it's funny, that's smart, but like, they started erasing what they play.
Wait, you can, you didn't see that, how?
They just, like, they just drew up, I'm just gonna post it, like, it's like, fucking public knowledge, like, this is what they do.
What, bro?
They're scared.
That is insane.
They're posting results with the characters out, I can see the background.
Yeah, you can see the background.
We literally see the background.
They're right there.
They're right there, I see Storm.
Storm, I see Storm, Rocket, Punisher, Thor, and Venom.
I see all three of those.
Wait a second.
Oh my god, bro, they wanna win.
KB is the Rocket player, okay.
That's very funny.
That is pretty funny.
I think, I don't know, they're, like, listening to me, cause I'm scouting, so they might have listened to me saying what they're playing.
Oh, they better not, they better not scratch out the whole thing.
My chat said we should reply with their lineup to scare them.
I completely agree with that.
I would love to do that, I want to do that so bad.
Guys, we gotta win, guys.
How did they know?
That's good tech, that's good tech, hold on, let's see.
Interesting.
That's funny, that's so funny.
I was just like, alright, what are they playing?
That's crazy.
But, no, this is the Spider-Man, they have Spider-Venom players for this one, but I don't think they're running it.
They don't seem to be, they're not running it, so.
I think they probably had it in the ban line.
Probably, no they didn't.
Their ban line was Black, the enemy team banned Magic and Black Panther on them.
Oh, so they have a lot of divers?
And then they also banned Wolverine, they have a Wolverine player, I know that, they have a Wolverine player.
Oh.
Ew.
Well, yeah, I'm right here, by the way.
Right here, my bad.
Is this a bracket?
Like, do we keep playing teams that keep winning?
Or is it just random?
Do we know?
I don't know.
I assume it's Swiss, like, if you win then you play another winning team, you know?
Probably is.
So the team we're fighting next is that one?
Yeah, I think it could be, because we were playing against teams that have won their games.
Are you guys grabbing Jay?
We go Beto first or Jay first?
Let's do Jay first.
We'll keep the rhythm like that.
Yeah, keep the rhythm, the back and forth rhythm.
Alright, I'll bring him in.
No, Beto.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Beto, go back to jail you go.
Back to jail.
I miss him already.
Hello, I'm back.
Welcome back, welcome back.
Thank you.
Did you see what happened?
Did you see in our little team chat, Jay?
Team chat?
Oh shit, what?
The team Rocket Raccoonantes.
Yeah.
They tried covering up all the characters, but you can still see the background.
That's so funny.
Wait, what?
I think they should not have made the group A result public.
I'm not going to lie.
They shouldn't have made this public, because you can see what they're playing against other teams.
The thing is, all of us can access it too, not just me.
That's really awkward.
I didn't even realize that you can see the characters in the background.
That was a cherry on top, I just realized that.
I feel like they should have just went to the match history and then screenshot it and then erased the thing.
Yeah.
That'd be a lot smarter.
We're waiting for 1, 2, 3, 4 more teams for their matches.
I see, we can chill for now.
Yeah, and then we have two more.
If we fight only Amidst, that's the other hard team in our group.
If we fight them after this, then the team after that wouldn't be as hard.
I see, I see.
That's the main thing we want to get out of their way.
I don't think we should run Classic 2-2-2 for them, because they run dive characters.
So I don't think we should run Triple Support.
Or we could run 3-3, we just need to ban Wolverine.
Because then their dive would do nothing against us.
It really depends.
Okay, I muted myself.
I'm nervous.
I'm fucking nervous this entire day.
I don't know if I'm playing well.
I feel like I'm making a lot of little mistakes.
I fixed it.
I fixed their image.
I made so many little mistakes.
I don't know if I'm doing well.
Am I doing okay, guys?
Please reassure me.
I was like, no, no way.
I was like, thank God, bro.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
I'm glad.
I'm glad that...
I'm glad that you guys think I'm doing okay.
I'm really happy.
Yeah, we're waiting for... the other teams aren't done yet.
There's like three teams that are still fighting.
Yeah, get them out of here.
This is our lobby.
We're not remaking.
I'll put Jay in here and Coney in here.
Coney, why are you leaving the lobby?
We're always here.
Why is Coney leaving?
I fixed their screenshot, but I feel like it's a BM.
Wait, what did you do?
Look in the chat.
I fixed it.
What is this?
Alright, analyzing the heights.
Analyzing the heights to see where they're at.
Okay, that's definitely not Raccoon.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I feel like I'm gonna make a suggestion and just be like, lock the group A result.
Like, lock it so we don't see the other teams.
That's like the easiest fix, to be fair.
I don't mind.
No, I don't mind not covering.
Cause like, I feel like on day two, people would just watch our VODs.
There's no point in covering it.
They'll just watch our VODs.
And they'll be like, well, these are what they play.
Cause I'm fucking watching VODs after.
To see who makes it.
What the fuck?
Group C is already playing.
Group C and D and F already have their games.
This is not fair.
They already got their group matchups.
We gotta wait.
They're progressing fast.
There's like teams that are just like, basically...
One more team left.
Just one more team and then we should be good.
I'm curious as to like, which team we're gonna...
Which team we're gonna fight?
I think most likely we're fighting the Oni one.
Let's see.
Cause who did they fight last time they fought 5Pixels?
I keep forgetting that I have another tournament after this.
I'm like, oh, I'll be done.
Yeah, but like...
No, you're not done, bro.
You got more work to do.
Yeah, you got a lot of work to do.
You wanna ditch that tournament?
You win more money for this one anyway.
Also, through how long this is lasting, I don't think I can play the first round.
They're gonna have to play without me.
Yeah, cause we're waiting.
I mean, yeah, we're waiting a lot.
Unless we like...
Like, we gotta get the last round really fast.
Round 4 just has to be like, super fast.
Yeah.
Or round 5.
We can finish round 5 fast too.
I gotta like, dip immediately.
Yeah, but you'll be warmed up by then.
I will.
My whole team will be asleep and I'll still be warmed up and ready.
I don't know.
Hog is still warming up right now.
He's the only one that's live.
Checking this... They're still playing.
Yeah, they're still playing.
Which team's still going?
It's the Island and Goonites.
They're still going, so we're waiting on that.
Oh my god, you're right.
They are still going.
It's on overtime.
How long is this overtime?
It's on... They're on overtime?
Oh my god.
I mean, they haven't posted screenshots yet of their matches, so...
We just wait.
Guys, I just know that like...
If I'm like super nervous right now, day 2, I'm gonna be a mess.
I'm gonna be a fucking mess on day 2.
Thank you guys.
I'm trying not to drink too much gamer stuff.
I haven't been drinking the gamer stuff anymore because I'm worried that if I drink too much, I'm gonna get too caffeinated.
Yeah, I'm thinking by then, I'm gonna stay up.
I'm gonna stay up just so I can be super tired by tonight.
Also, I'm not used to waking up so early too, so my body's not used to it and everything.
So, yeah.
And then like, I'm trying not to get too caffeinated right now because I get like super jittery if I get too caffeinated.
So I'm just drinking water.
I need to remember to feed Doki Ember Doge in 2 hours too.
Please.
It happened.
Or is their game... Their game's not finished yet.
No!
They all get to play!
All the other teams are playing!
3 groups are already playing!
No!
I'm gonna start scouting.
I'm gonna scout.
Okay.
What was the final stage?
Group G.
Alright, who's their best player in group... Who's their best team in group G?
Alright.
Scouting time.
All I care about...
Okay.
Oh, this team is... This team is actually decent.
Thank God.
We don't... We can't look.
I'm just gonna make sure I watch VODs after this too.
I hate the in-between.
The in-between is the roughest part.
Just waiting.
Oh wait, they posted it!
Okay, they won.
Okay, nice.
They won.
But thank God.
Did they actually go overtime?
Okay, we're good.
We find the Oni inmates.
I knew it.
Is this the hard team?
Yeah, that's the hard team.
That's the hard team.
That's the... Okay, who do we want to ban for them?
I think Wolverine, right?
I kind of want to go with the Rocket pick.
Maybe ban Rocket or... I mean...
Because they do punish your Bucky, so...
Banning Rocket is good as well.
Yeah, let's just ban Rocket then.
I'll give you the idea for them.
Here, this is their...
Invite this person.
This was the one I researched earlier too, so...
And for them, they played...
Yeah, they mostly try to do Punisher.
They do Punisher, Bucky, and Wolverine.
Should we ban Wolverine or do you think you're...
I mean, you're definitely the better Wolverine, but...
Of course.
For our tanks though, would they be...
Okay.
Oh gosh.
That's the thing.
Because we could do Wolverine, Rocket...
Do you...
Oh gosh, I was like building that up for like a minute.
Oh, bless you.
Yeah, bless you.
What are you thinking?
Yeah, look at this team.
Like I said, this team has the highest average in our group.
Alright, let's see.
They're all...
Oh.
Nevermind.
Fuck, they are all...
Okay.
Yeah, no, they're...
They...
Gomez, they hot.
They fucking scrape their characters.
Of course, they're gonna hide their profiles.
They fucking scrape their hero pool off of existence.
Wait, what about Venom, Spidey?
Yeah, they want Venom, Spider-Man too.
We could do...
We could ban Rocket, Spider.
How much ping do you get to Dallas, Jay?
Okay, let's see.
205.
There's no difference.
Oh, we can't because...
205, what do you get now?
No, but Limeu.
225.
Yeah, I think it's okay.
We prefer...
We can't...
Oh, Limeu.
For our EU player.
We'll just be like, we can't for our EU player.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then we have ping advantage, oh my god.
Let's go.
Yeah.
They're all green bar.
Yeah, they're all...
Yeah, they're all green.
But maybe it's like a little bit higher, maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe the lag will throw them off a little bit.
I mean, for DPS, they'll throw them off.
What did we change?
Oh, they wanted Dallas server, but we can't because we're like...
Oh yeah, Dallas would fuck me a little bit.
Yeah.
Like, they're all green bar.
We're literally the only team that's not green.
Yeah.
So, like, we have to play on East Coast.
Let us know when...
30 MS difference for me.
Which is a lot when it takes me over 100 and something.
Wait, I just thought of it.
Yeah, the Thor player has a Thor icon.
They don't run Thor all the time.
They run...
They...
Is that the Venom player?
That's their dive play.
They do Thor...
Wait, what was it?
King...
They do...
Yeah, Thor and Venom.
What's the map for this one?
This one, it's Convoy.
It's the low-key map in Convoy.
Low-key map Convoy.
The Yggdrasil path.
Yggdrasil.
Yggdrasil path, yeah.
They're ready, by the way.
They're ready?
But are we ready?
I'm ready.
Everyone's spoken except for Lymu.
Oh, yeah, I'm ready.
Sorry.
Okay, Lymu's here.
Just chillin'.
And Coneyboy is here, right?
Yeah, I'm here.
Of course.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, do we invite anyone?
No spectators?
No.
No spectators.
We're good?
No casting for this one.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We don't have to wait.
Yeah, I didn't see anybody at me for casting, so...
I'm curious if they'll target ban you, Gomez.
I feel like they will.
Eh, nothing now.
I think you've been target banned this entire... like, the last two teams.
I'll have fun.
Starlord.
Starlord, yay!
You just couldn't go one game without banning Starlord.
Oh, we do Rocket first, right?
Rocket first?
Yeah, we do Rocket first.
I can't have what I want.
This is so sad.
Who are you protecting?
Do we protect the thing, or...?
No, they want Punisher.
They want Punisher and Bucky a lot.
If N gets banned, I'll play Mag.
Your call.
If you want to save Luna or whatever.
Let's just...
We probably need Namor if they're going double dive, right?
Yeah, let's just save Namor.
We can protect...
Thing, thing, thing, thing, thing.
Thing, thing.
Protect the thing.
Thing, thing, thing, thing.
Oh my goodness, bro.
Protect the thing.
I was hearing, like, three different things, so I did not know.
I heard Luna, Namor, then thing.
So, we'll go based off of what their last ban is, okay?
Yeah.
Whatever their last ban is, we can play off of it.
They're not fucking banning me.
I mean, you play Wolverine.
They protected Wolverine.
Yeah, I'll just do that.
No Luna, so they will have...
Okay, so...
So, if we're basing off of that ban, we still have...
We'll go with Spider-Man.
Yeah, and Spidey.
I think it would be better to ban Venom, though.
Oh, Venom?
Okay.
Jay's Venom is good, though.
Or, Jay, what do you want?
Venom or Strange?
Which one?
I'm feeling Strange.
Spider, Spider, Spider.
I'm banning Venom.
I'm banning Venom, yeah.
No!
Okay, it's okay, then.
It's okay.
Because he said Strange, I'm like, okay, he's feeling Strange, fine.
It's time to get Strange.
Alright, we go...
I don't know if we should do Adam, too, because this team is a decent team.
Are we attacking or defending?
We're defending first.
I'll go Cloak first, then.
Alright.
I don't know if we should go... yeah, I don't think Adam's too risky for this.
Especially that Wolverine.
Nope, I'm ready.
Wait, can you give me a Pax in the beginning?
Yeah, I can, I can.
Okay.
You can do the fly thing.
Oh, my one time, I picked...
Oh, wait, we banned Rocket, idiot.
Oh, shit!
We were the ones that banned Rocket.
Fuck, yeah.
I can't get the jump pack, though.
But they don't have it, too.
Okay, I have...
Based on how their Wolverine plays, I will probably... I might swap to Magneto.
Yep.
Okay.
Alright.
Mag should be the better pick here, since they're probably gonna go Pantheon.
Yeah, I feel so as well, because if I get kidnapped, I'm gonna have like...
The thing is, if they run Mag, I don't have shields.
Yeah, strange.
They have Storm, yeah.
I might just grab Storm out of the air if he flies up high enough.
Yeah, Thor.
I'm gonna walk in right now, okay?
Oh, never mind.
I think I'm gonna go... I'm gonna walk in now.
I'm gonna go for a grab.
Hook up their Wolverine, up top.
Yeah, I'm looking for you, I'm looking for you.
Watch out grab, watch out grab, watch out grab.
Oh, fuck.
I can't do any better, yeah.
Yeah, it's my bad.
I'm going Mag already.
Okay, yeah.
I'm looking at Storm right now.
I missed my grab.
Oh!
I can't, yeah.
You haven't used your passive yet.
Oh, Coney, watch out.
Just pocket Coney, pocket Coney.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I tried to shift.
They're doing a lot of fucking damage.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get Shurda out of here.
Yep.
I'm not sure what happened, I tried to shift out, but...
It might be better for me to just go Flylock.
Actually...
They walk in.
We have to soon.
Yeah, we gotta walk up.
Yeah, you gotta walk up.
You gotta walk up, you gotta walk up, you gotta walk up.
Walk up, walk up, walk up, walk up, walk up, walk up.
Yeah, we're on it, we're on it.
We have Lemons ult, we have Lemons ult.
Oh, they think I'm actually going to catch Flylock.
Don't use it, don't use it.
Yeah, I'm holding.
No need to use any ults here.
Just regroup, regroup here.
Do we keep, do we keep the thing with us?
I don't know if we should.
It should be good.
It should be good against the thing.
Or with the thing, it should be good against that.
I don't have ult, we have to use this to...
Here, here, here.
Nice.
It's fine.
I will here.
Stacked it.
Okay, I'm going to look for something.
Okay.
I can throw you in too.
I got ulted up.
We have to use...
What are we using?
Their Wolf is going to ult, their Wolf is going to ult, watch out.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Now we can copy, we can copy that.
Okay, alright.
I'm holding in a second.
I have to dodge.
I got shields.
Oh, he's up, he's up.
Okay.
Sure.
Got ult.
They, they, hold corner, hold corner, hold corner.
Hold corner.
Yeah, I'm holding, I'm holding, I'm holding.
Okay.
There's no support ult.
Now, can we, can we ult the corner with Shoto, Shoto?
Yeah, yeah.
I got, I got kidnapped, I got kidnapped.
I...
You should not hit me.
Yeah.
We're all down.
I think...
We have to change something up.
Yeah, we need a swap.
We have to swap something.
Do you do trips, trip support, or this for, I don't know.
We can do triple, we can do triple support.
Then I go Bucky.
I feel like we don't have enough healing somehow.
Can we, I don't know if we can touch this.
We don't have ultimate.
Oh, we can give it, we can give it.
Give it, okay, give it.
JJ back up, JJ back up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, backing back up, backing back up.
Because the only reason I didn't go Loki was because I was worried they had Bucky, sure.
Good swap.
I don't think they have a Bucky player.
We...
Oh, we have Limbo's ult.
Let me, let me try and get her.
I have it, I have it.
There you go, there you go.
Okay, nice.
I am...
Wolf down, wolf down, wolf down.
Thorin, Thorin, Thorin, Thorin, Thorin.
I'm pushing up, pushing up.
Yeah.
Thorin one.
Yeah, looking for it.
I have dash in three, two, one, I'm gonna run in.
You're gonna be by yourself when you run in.
You're by yourself, you're by yourself.
You can't E me, you can't E me, you can't E me.
Back up if you can, back up if you can, back up if you can.
Right here, right here, right here on me.
I'm gonna pick him up, I'm gonna pick him up here.
Nice, nice, nice.
They phased.
I don't know.
I'm gonna use this to regroup.
Yeah, we're still good.
Yeah, I'm pushing up, I'm pushing up.
Push up with this, push up with this.
Yeah.
I have ult, one sec.
I'm getting out, I'm getting out, I'm getting out.
Yeah, I got it, I got it, I got it.
I'm shielding, I'm shielding, I'm shielding.
I'm baiting, looking at, baiting out.
I have no bubble, I have no bubble here.
I'm gonna get back, I'm gonna get back.
Storm ult, Storm ult.
I shifted, I shifted.
Oh my god, he ulted!
Use this, use this, use this, use this, use this, use this.
Wolf on, Wolf on, Wolf on.
I have both, I have both.
Oh fuck.
It's fine, stay in the, stay in the cloak ult, stay in the cloak ult, stay in the cloak ult.
Yeah, okay, yeah, I'm staying, I'm staying, I'm staying, I'm staying.
Right here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna storm, yeah.
Can we, can we kill Storm?
We can, we can, we can, we can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's portaled out, he's portaled out.
She's necked out.
Yeah.
We don't have any support ults and they have strange ult, they have strange ult and floor ult.
They have strange ult and floor ult.
Lime has to build it up.
Lime, Lime, you should heal, Lime heal more.
Yeah, yeah, I'm letting her heal, I'm letting her heal.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm letting her heal right now.
And then she can get a full charge.
Hold there.
I'm going right here, right here.
Yeah.
Okay, she'll ult.
There's nobody, there's nobody with him.
Lime?
Yeah, we need to be careful of the strange.
They might portal, they might portal block.
Just keep going.
Don't hear it.
Yeah, they didn't.
I'm rocking right, Lime I'm off heat a little bit, so you heal me okay?
Okay.
Lime, Lime, Lime, come back, come back, come back, come back.
He's portaling, he's portaling, he's portaling, he's portaling, he's portaling.
Okay, now walk out, walk out, walk out.
And you got ult.
You feel that, do you feel that?
We got touch points here.
Oh fuck.
I'm getting on point.
You feel it, you feel it feel it.
We're on, we're on.
Yeah, I'm touching point, I'm touching point, I'm touching point.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
Welcome to the Dark Force Dimension.
Disappear!
Oh my god, fuck.
Oh, I'm 96!
Big clobber, big clobber, big clobber, big clobber!
Fuck me!
Oh my god, three people annoyed me.
I couldn't live there.
I fucking slammed that and hit him.
That's so sad.
I don't know we should play this game.
We're being too aggressive a bit.
Yeah, I can swap to Mag if he wants to play Strange.
Yeah, I can swap to Strange, yeah.
We have to change something.
Okay, I think Coney's playing a little too aggressive.
Because the thing is you're supposed to be good against that.
So we can probably just play around corners, Coney.
Don't really do anything that intensive.
The thing is we have nothing to counter the Strange ult too.
Because the Strange gets a free ult on us every time.
So we have nothing to shield us from the Strange.
Yeah, Mag is better.
Mag helps here.
Big problem.
Yeah.
Okay, so let's do that then.
It's good.
Okay.
Why not?
Yeah, the Storm is definitely punishing Coney's thing.
Yeah.
Should be good running this though.
We want, actually...
Sue's good against that.
We have the clones.
Luke is good just mid-fight ult.
We could...
Okay, if you want to, you can go Mantis against that, but...
Mantis?
I can try.
If you want, if you want.
I don't really have the team up though.
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking too.
No, they do cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
It's like the defensive ult, we need more defensive ults here.
They literally have too many aggression ults for us.
Yeah.
I have the Storm.
Hold them in.
Hold in there, hold in the Wolf.
I'm, I, I blinded.
Wolf no passive, no passive.
See, look at that.
Wolf play is a little, a little...
A little... not aware.
Okay, look at the, look at the...
Thor, Thor, Thor.
I blinded him, I blinded him again.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
Okay, Wolf, Wolf, Wolf, Wolf, Wolf.
That's good, that's really good.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
Ashe is three.
Holding.
Yeah, you guys push, I can heal, I can heal.
I have no bubble, I have no bubble.
Okay, Coney, but I'm with you, bro.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
Nice, big, big, big, big.
Big, huge, huge, huge, huge.
Push out, push out, push out, push out.
Good job, good job, good job.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
That's an...
I think...
Do we chase?
Okay, we're on point, we're on point.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine, it's fine.
Coney supports his pull.
Pushing turret, it's fine.
Can we portal this?
I think we can do that.
They're probably portal.
They have no ults to actually...
I blinded him, I blinded him, I blinded him.
Nice, nice, nice.
They ulted, they ulted.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't have any support ults here.
I'm on a slam, I'm on a slam too here.
Yeah.
Uh...
90% on shuriken.
It's two, it's two.
I'm getting blocked, I'm getting blocked.
I'm done.
Do we have any support ults?
We should.
Use slam, use slam.
Look at Coney.
Look at Coney, look at Coney.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Shush, shush, shush, shush.
I'm with you.
I'm on Bucky, I'm on Bucky, I'm on Bucky.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kill Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Wolverine, Wolverine, Wolverine, Wolverine.
Think, think, think, think, think.
Wolve, wolve, wolve, wolve.
Nice.
Nice, good job.
Holy fuck, that's good, that's good.
Okay.
And you guys still have both support ults?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
They use, uh, they use cloak ult.
How the fuck do you build it so fast?
They have Captain America now.
You ulted so quick, bro.
They have strange ult here, so...
Holy shit.
I ulted at the same time as them, to be honest.
I guess it makes sense.
Do you want me to try and ult the strange ult?
Uh, yeah, yeah.
It's better for you to ult the strange ult.
Check corners, check corners.
You play further back then if they're gonna...
because then he might try to ult you.
Captain America, Captain America.
On the left, on the left.
Captain America.
Okay.
Do you want to do a little bit more dives?
I could, I could aggressive ult this.
Actually.
Kappa's one.
I'm gonna do this, I'm Kappa.
Yeah.
Nice.
Nice, fuck, he's dead.
Okay, he fell, he fucked up.
He fucked up so hard, nice.
Yeah, look at this thing.
Strange, strange, strange, strange.
Go for front lines, front lines.
Yeah, yeah, go, go, go.
That feels really good.
Fuck off, strange.
What the hell?
She's one!
Boom!
Nice.
Good job.
Alright, they have, you have to ult the strange ult first.
I got one.
Yeah.
I got ulted for this.
Push car, push car, push car.
Get my cramped tank.
Best ult.
The best ult in the world.
I have ult for this.
I'm gonna try and see if I can flip the strange.
Oh, I'm slept.
Fuck, oh, they slept me.
Use ult.
Nice, I'm down.
I got slept.
Alright, we just play around corner, play around corner.
We don't have to push it.
I'm pulling back, I'm pulling back, I'm pulling back.
If he feeds, I can ult this.
Nevermind.
I have E, yes.
I have ult soon, I have ult soon, I have ult soon.
I'm pulling back, I'm pulling back.
It's not strange, by the way.
No, they used it.
Oh, they used it?
Yeah, they used it.
I got fucking kidnapped.
I have to kill myself.
I can ult this, I can ult this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have his ult, I have his ult.
Yeah, I blinded them.
I'm pulling back, I pulled in their Mantis.
I'm pulling them in, I'm pulling them in.
I think we just die, we just full die.
Oh, shit.
I was going to say, we should full die.
Just full die, just full die, don't use anything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm doing my pulls too early for my shift.
What am I doing?
Can't do this on your actual tournament, Gomez.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy.
Their Mantis ulted.
They have strange ult soon, I think.
Yeah, they do have ult soon as well.
Did they use a thing ult?
No.
No, no, they'll have it.
I got ult up.
You can go behind them and ult them if you want.
Alright, I'm going to do it.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going behind.
One second.
Doki, am I ulting first or you?
I'm ulting first.
Walk in, walk in, walk in hard.
Yeah, yeah, go, go, go.
Look for it, look for it.
Go, go, go.
Oh my god, you actually got him.
Wait, Mantis, Mantis.
Oh my god.
I'm shielding you.
It's 6v5.
Get 6v5.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pulling.
I'm using it, I'm using it, I'm using it, I'm using it.
We have ult, we have ult.
How the fuck did he get...
Monkey one, monkey one, monkey one, monkey one.
I have to go for Mantis.
Yeah, Mantis.
Okay, Mantis, Mantis, Mantis.
We're killing Ice.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Good job, good job, good job.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Walk it, yeah, walk it, walk it.
Yeah, walk it, walk it.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Fuck this guy.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I think that was probably worth...
He kind of ran through everyone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I went aggression ult that.
Because I knew we had the advantage there.
Yeah, that's fair.
I still have my ult because it felt weird just to do it for myself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They used...
Use yours as the first defensive ult.
Strange not high ground.
I'm pushing turret first.
Fuck, he's alone.
They have Adam now, by the way.
They have Adam.
Okay.
I'll run a Korean comp.
Korean comp.
Okay, no pull.
But maybe they're not that good at it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Push up, push up.
Push this, push this, push this.
Let's get active.
Get active here.
Get active, bro, get active.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going in.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god, it's getting active.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god, Cody.
Shit, block.
Adam rezzing in between us.
Oh my god, I hit nothing, bro.
They have aggression ults for us.
They have strange ults?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm backing up, backing up.
Wait, I built Tracer.
Yeah, Tracer, Tracer, Tracer.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Reset, reset, reset.
I got you, I got you.
Oh, they ulted, they ulted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming out, I'm coming out.
Careful, Kuni.
Yep.
I pulled the moon, I pulled the moon.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
That's such a big pick.
I got shields, okay, I got shields.
Don't be afraid, don't be afraid.
Fuck, fuck, you what?
Big thing, ulted, big thing is ulted.
Big thing is ulted.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
He missed, he missed, he missed, he missed.
I'm using it, I'm using it.
Getting backup, getting backup.
Guys, go active, go active.
I'm using it, I'm using it.
I'm with you.
Focus change, focus change, focus change.
Watch out.
Med this one, med this one.
Strange low, strange low.
Nice, nice, nice.
Strange is dead.
Trans right here, ting, ting.
Focus strange, focus on it, focus on it.
Nice, nice.
Nice job.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
He's getting active on the pen!
Holy shit.
Cody, you're doing fucking fantastic right now.
Yeah, yeah.
When you start playing pass it, like more or less aggression is really good.
No, no.
Let's do it again, one more time.
You know what, you're doing fantastic.
You just lit up my chat.
I was doing the same thing over there.
The brain cell.
I think when I have cloak off first, I'm just going to use it as an aggressional.
I think that has been working out for us.
Yes.
Yeah, I like that.
I like it.
Yeah.
We'll use the Loki and the Invisible Man's defensive.
I thought their Bucky would be more of a problem.
It doesn't seem like it.
I think he like...
Missed.
Blessed him in the face.
Their Wolverine storm was the problem.
Yeah.
It's just the thing hard counters the Wolverine.
If you just shift, he can't grab you.
And if you press shift, he can't move.
And if I pull him, he can't move anymore.
He just can't move against us.
We should be popping off now.
We got less than...
We're a minute down, but I think that's fine.
Yeah.
We just have to have a really good push.
Yeah, have a good push.
And then we hold super well.
Careful.
That's him.
Yeah, Moon Knight.
Nice.
He's still one there.
Oh my god.
I'm lucky.
It's okay.
They have Groot.
Hold them in.
Groot can die.
He was so close.
They might get Moon Knight ult on us.
Yeah, they might have Moon Knight ult.
Be careful.
They're going to have it soon, I think.
I'm not building ult fast enough.
Hold them in again.
Hold them in.
I have ult soon.
I can't skin it.
Hold them in again.
I'm out.
I'm out of it.
We have support ult coming in.
I'm using it.
I got it.
Big fight.
Let's focus up.
They're going to have Groot ult.
We have to prepare for that.
Yeah, we play back.
We have to prepare for Groot ult.
I ulted.
I can't fucking kill them.
I have ult.
I pulled in Moon Knight.
Oh no.
I can't kill anything yet.
We'll just survive.
I'm coming.
I'm waiting here.
I'm touching point.
I'm sitting on it.
Pop it.
Zoning.
Keep zoning up.
I got Moon.
I pulled in their tank.
I'm touching point.
I'm staying on point.
Storm one.
I'm one.
Yeah, we don't have...
They stacked ults.
What do we do for this?
If they're running this, I don't know if we should run...
the thing.
I don't know.
I'm down to swap to Strange.
Do you want Strange back?
Uh...
Can I?
They don't have Rocket.
If they're going to run Moon Knight and Groot, we can't run Loki.
Because they're just farming our clones.
You know what?
We could pull out our old classic.
We could pull out the triple tank.
And just hold our own corner the entire time.
Right now, we're not playing...
What?
I'm thinking...
Because they can also go Groot.
I still want to keep the thing.
Because it's super easy.
Super easy to hold their own corners.
I'm going to play solo Wolverine.
We just play super patient.
We just rotate ults.
They're going to try to push into us.
Should I still be Loki and just be more spread?
Yeah.
We're going to use...
We're going to use Doki's ult for more of an engage.
Then, Shadow, you can copy Limeu's whenever they come in.
Yeah.
I'm just worried about Storm, too.
And Moon Knight ult, though.
I think Shadow should copy me.
Yeah, I want to copy Doki's ult.
Yeah, copy me.
Because they'll just Moon Knight the ult.
Okay.
You have to play more passive here.
Do not be aggressive.
Just play our support ult and just play off the time.
That's all we're doing.
I play my pulls, and then we just play around corner.
That's all we do.
Gomez, we lose this against them.
You have to play loser bracket.
I do, I know.
I'll tell them.
Okay, I'm going to look for a grab here.
Whenever they walk in a little bit.
I'm looking.
I pulled in the Moon Knight.
Yeah, I used blind already.
I got it.
Go to the wall.
The wall's open.
Yeah, I'm going to look for a play.
For a grab.
I'm here.
You used your passive, so you have to play more.
I'm playing super passive.
You're walled.
Tank's walled.
He might have Moon Knight ult.
He's going to have that.
I think I'm blind.
I hit three.
We have to push on point.
We have Luna.
I'm going to come back with strength.
We have second ult.
I don't have it yet.
I'm 97.
I got it.
I have TP.
They're going to ult me.
Storm killed me.
You're walled up.
Look at Moon Knight.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I'm on it.
I'm trying my best to heal you guys.
Look at their supports, okay?
We have no support ults.
We need to get picks here.
Three, two, one.
Nice.
Come back.
We have no support ults here.
Look.
We play around with support ults, okay?
We don't have any.
You're walled up.
Careful.
GG.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
We lost two.
Oh, no.
I'm dead.
It's up to you.
Huge!
Oh, no.
They're all fucking low.
Jay backed into the ball.
That's my bad.
I didn't know I had to go to the right.
We were so close.
That's my bad.
I'll just range.
Fuck that.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my lord.
If we do get 1-1 with them, we have a tiebreaker.
I don't know who wins.
Yeah, because if we do 1-1, if we win the next one, I don't know who's going to go to the winner's bracket.
We just do.
The thing is, do we run in battle here?
Or...
Up to you.
Is everyone battle here?
I think battle can be our mag.
We can try that.
Okay.
Goodbye, duck.
Sorry, Shoto.
No duck.
Oh, duck.
Lucky.
Alright.
What's the next one?
Symbiotic.
Do we just run 3-3 then?
For this?
For this team?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
I just started for no reason.
What the fuck?
Hold on.
Everyone leave.
Leave.
Scrim moment.
Sorry.
I usually just insta-put us in if it's a scrim.
Whoopsie.
Okay.
Oh, sub's into my support.
Battle's gonna play mag.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
We're running back up.
Hello, hello.
Close, guys.
That was so close.
Yeah, it was.
We had like...
Oh, my god.
Our support was so close.
From Zo.
Yeah, it sucked.
I got separated by the moon.
Yeah, I tried to heal.
I backed to the...
I was the only one that backed fully up because I was too far for it to back into you guys.
Yeah, I had to swerve to the right and Magneto was like, hello there.
I'm lucky.
I think we should run 3-3 then.
And then, Gomez, you should be on Strange.
Down.
I am completely down.
Can you swap?
Oh, yeah.
I can't move their spectator.
Wait, I can't move him.
What?
No, he can move himself.
Usually, I can move him, but he's not like me.
I'm lucky.
So, is this like a Swiss style?
I thought we played 5 teams.
So, what happens here?
Oh, we play 4 teams.
If we get 1-1, it goes to tiebreaker, but I don't know how the tiebreaker works.
If they win the tiebreaker, if they win the tiebreaker, we go to loser's round.
I see, okay.
Nice.
Let me tell them maybe an hour after...
No, it's a long one.
We have like several games.
Like 3-4 games.
Okay, let me ask if they're ready.
Oh, nevermind.
They said one sec.
I don't know if we should go Adam with our 3-3.
Do you think Adam is still okay with 3-3, or do we...
It usually is.
Should be good.
I'll go in with Adam then and see how it goes.
It's either that, or we can do...
If we want you on cloak, if we still want to run the cloak, or if we're doing the Sue, I don't know.
Could run the Adamantus Loki, or the Sue Loki Adam.
Depends.
What's your opinion?
You're the most experienced against this team.
I think...
Okay, we're obviously going to ban Groot.
They pulled out the cheesy shit.
I don't care if they pull out Venom.
I'm going to be completely real.
We can just ban out the Groots.
We can just do...
We don't need to ban Rocket.
I don't think.
They want to do cheesy stuff.
I think maybe the Rocket ban would still be better.
Just do Groot Rocket then.
Yeah.
This is a cheesy team.
I mean, they ban Luna.
Do we have lack of defensible for their cheese?
Yep, that's what they're going for.
I think we should protect...
I think we should protect Mag then, right?
Uh, yep.
Okay.
We'll just do that.
They're coming up with strats right now against us.
Thinking too much.
I'm a little sad.
It was so winnable.
It was just little mistakes here and there.
It was really just little mistakes.
Honestly, I think we definitely should have swapped stuff earlier during attack.
We were...
We took too long to swap things.
I should have called for the swap.
I should have called for the swap during attack earlier because I was not...
I could feel that that was not the right comp.
Yeah.
When the Moon Knight ulted, it was very unfortunate that some people backed up into the Moon Knight ult.
I definitely should be more vocal.
We all just made little mistakes here and there.
I think like...
Yeah.
We gotta be more proactive with counters.
We were brute forcing things that we shouldn't be brute forcing.
I just hope we win.
If we win this, I hope we win the tiebreaker.
Because then if we don't win the tiebreaker, we play longer.
I don't want to play longer.
Yeah.
This is the...
Alright.
Are they ready yet?
Are
they ready?
Oh, they're ready.
They're ready, by the way.
Alright.
I'm ready, then.
Is everyone here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Naimo, are you here?
Yeah, yeah, I'm here.
Alright, let's start this.
Let's get it.
Let's get the 1-1 and bring it to the tiebreaker.
I'm gonna read up the tiebreaker rules if we do get the 1-1.
Alright.
I guess...
I run Adam here, then.
You didn't do bands, Gomez.
You did quick play.
We don't have bands.
Oh, my god.
I'm actually... Okay, just tell him to leave.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
I messed it up twice.
Leader, friends...
Invite, invite, invite, invite...
Alright.
Let's get this quickly.
Boom.
Get this guy on my team.
I'm over here.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
You think I can sub in Rye for it?
No, that guy's asleep.
I'll bring in Rye.
Maybe I'll just bring in Hogs.
Let me get him on my PC real quick.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Yeah, leave the Spider-Man shit open.
I don't think Spider-Man's even good into triple sport anyway.
Yeah, it's not.
Five characters are not good against triple.
Guess what we're running.
Keep band line, but then we band group, so then they can't cheese it.
Yeah, band group first.
Okay, group first.
Alright, no, no, no.
Do rocket.
Oh, rocket?
Okay.
Rocket first.
And then keep Mag safe?
Yeah.
Yeah, keep Mag safe.
As long as we have Mag, we'll be fine.
I don't want to think too much ahead.
Yeah, just see what they band.
Okay, thank god.
I was like, are they gonna protect group?
If they did, I was gonna say they listened.
If we did triple tank, triple support, would Wolverine be bad?
Would Wolverine fuck us over?
Uh, kinda.
Kinda.
We just have to be playing around abilities.
See, this is why this is why I'm thinking, hey, Wolverine wouldn't be that good against the thing.
Since the thing can frontline the entire time, take a lot of the sponge damage, right?
Then me and Gabe can kinda go for our little plays on the Strange and Mag.
And then we just rotate ult.
If I feel like we don't have enough heals, I'm gonna swap to Cloak.
Yep.
I'll try out with Adam first.
When people get pulled in, if we do get pulled in, get ready to link.
Yeah, it's so fun.
But if you guys get pulled too far, I don't know if I can.
Yep.
I think we run triple.
If we're gonna run triple tank in the future, I think we should put Betel in for 3-3.
Just cause Betel is their mag specialist.
Alright.
Seems good.
Don't do that.
And I think he also has to...
I think it might be really difficult to mag ult with 200 ping.
I mean, to be fair, he's doing pretty good for 200 ping though.
Yeah, he's doing really good with 200 ping.
But I wanna see if there's...
Careful Shado.
He might be TPing.
Maybe not.
They might just be... Oh, they might be scouting.
To see where to TP.
They could use that to scout.
They have Punisher and Bucky, I think, right?
Yeah, they do.
Remember not to be too aggressive.
I'm grabbed.
You're fine.
I got him.
Got my E too quick.
Alright, now play patient again.
I'm back.
They literally cannot do anything on the Wolverine as long as we just space it and you frontline.
Okay,
Wolverine's gonna be close again.
Can you back up a little bit, Bubble?
Yep.
Okay.
I have ult soon.
We can copy.
Let me know if you guys are low.
I'm ulting here.
I'm still ulting.
I have my ult too, waiting.
I got blocked.
Next ult soon.
Nice cancel.
I'm grabbed.
That got all of them.
I don't have ult here.
I'm just gonna...
I don't have rez.
Potion exploded, I think.
Might be just be better to...
Maybe it is better to just do.
Maybe.
Oh, no, but...
No, I think we should be fine.
If we need to, I just...
They used change ult and clobbering ult.
But we also used clobbering, right?
Yeah, we did.
We changed.
They still have strange eye.
It's because of the stun.
Oh, okay, okay.
We should have it soon then.
I'll get ready for rez then.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I have ult here.
I'm gonna play more passive then.
I used my shift.
I used my shift, so I'm careful.
Everything is afk.
Lucky one.
I'm gonna get grabbed, but I'm gonna fly out.
I'm reloading.
Good.
Play patient, that's all we do.
Don't do anything.
I'm backing out from you guys.
Just in case.
I want ult here.
Give me a second.
I'm just making it so they can't move.
Fuck.
Watch eye, watch eye.
I got him, I got him.
Still gonna be looking for eye.
I almost got his passive out.
I can't move.
Fuck me, man.
I went around the wrong way.
He's looking, he's looking.
Isolate us.
Oh, I got grabbed.
They're gonna stand straight.
We have no defensive ult here.
Wolverine passive down.
They have Wolverine ult too.
We're giving a lot of space.
He's looking for eye on top.
On top, on top.
We're giving a lot of space, guys.
Yeah, we are giving too much space.
Nice, nice, nice.
Push back a bit.
Watch the cosmos field.
I feel like myself again.
Walk a little bit.
Push it back down this hallway.
This time, I'm feeling power.
Just watch above.
He might pop down.
I actually ult around this corner if they come in.
Nice, nice, nice.
They have thing ult.
They have thing ult and strange ult.
They have all their ults for this fight.
Except for Bucky.
The only ult they don't have is Bucky.
Are they portaling?
What?
They're portaling, they're portaling.
Careful, careful.
We can just rotate.
Over here, over here.
Dropping.
They stocked it.
I can look for ult.
I have ult.
I'm ready for you.
Okay.
I got you, I got you.
Good ult.
I still have my ult.
We don't have tank ult.
We just rotate around Shadows.
And Lime moves ult.
Did they use clobber?
Okay, they have wolverine ult.
No, they haven't.
They have wolverine ult too.
Do you go first?
Yes, I go first.
Actually, you react first.
Because I have cast time.
You react first.
Watch out, Coney.
They're gonna go for grab.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I got ult, I got ult.
Do you have ult?
I don't have ult.
Yeah, yeah, good ult, good ult.
Okay, where are you, where are you Lime?
I'm next to you, I'm next to you.
I'm ulting next.
Yeah, yeah, I comboed it.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
I blocked it.
What the...
I have snaps, I have snaps.
I stole them too.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Okay, okay, it's good.
They don't have TP, we just kill here, we just kill here.
Strange thing, thing, thing, thing, thing!
Yeah, yeah, I'm looking, I'm looking.
Strange, strange, strange!
One, one, one, strange, strange, strange!
Nice, nice, good job, good job.
On top, someone get that healer up there.
I see him.
She jumped down.
Let me know if you guys need heals, I can...
I missed a link, I missed a link, just in case.
I'm just gonna shift for you guys, I'm shifting.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
Great, strange, got it.
We're good, we're good.
Nice.
Good job, good job.
Spider man.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff!
There's a Jeff, kill the Jeff!
Kill the Jeff!
Got him.
Nice.
Perfect, good job.
Sorry for not holding it, but I was like, without holding it, I got really worried about it.
Good, good.
See, the Wolverine can't really do anything here.
Almost top skins.
This one.
Good shit, guys.
Yeah, I got this.
I'm gonna look at the tiebreaker and see what it says.
We always portal first, we always portal first, right?
Yeah, we can.
We can portal here.
Okay, okay.
I mean, if they don't ban strange, then we get Starlord or Luna, which is pretty nice, too.
That leaves Namor open, probably, but I don't know if we want to do that.
I mean, we are not gonna play against this team.
Oh, for the tiebreaker?
Yeah, the tiebreaker is based off...
I don't know where it is.
Tiebreaker.
I'm trying to figure out where it is.
So both of us are gonna have to do tiebreaker, I see.
Yeah, we both have to do tiebreakers, but against different teams?
It's based off of performance.
So I don't know how... I guess we gotta do really well in our last game, then.
For our performance.
Oh, actually, no.
They have a Skrull girl.
I'm gonna put us all literally on point.
I'm putting us straight on point.
I'm pulling DS instantly.
Their Thing is speeding.
Thing is shooting.
I need heal.
I got you guys.
I'm with you.
I'm on the mag.
Mag can die.
Mag can die here, too.
I'm on Sue.
Sue one.
Yeah, Skrull dead.
Skrull dead.
I got one-shot.
You exploded.
What the fuck?
Dude, the mag one-shot me.
Okay.
Beautiful.
So, now we're gonna want to...
Whenever we save Link, for the Moon Knight ult.
Okay, okay, okay.
And we know when they have it.
I'm gonna play more back, okay?
Compared to you guys, because I don't wanna be up closer to the Moon Knight.
The only time I'm gonna put my clone up is for a shift to save somebody.
So I play far back.
I'm playing, like, true backline right now.
I'm pushing up.
I'm pushing up for Gomez.
Okay, I'm in the middle.
Moon Knight up there.
Yeah, yeah, watch out.
Oh,
shit, I have the useful bomb.
They don't have ult yet, so it's okay.
I'm just backing out.
Careful.
That was low.
Careful, they're gonna get...
They're getting in.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Captain America low, Captain America low.
Captain America very low.
Yeah, we got you, we got you.
I'm taking your ult.
I'm going in.
Focus Sing.
Sing, Sing, Sing.
Sing one.
Sing dead.
Yeah,
we can get Axe.
We can still get Axe.
Yeah, get Axe.
Get that.
Push, push, push, push.
I'm on Galio.
I'm pushing Cap.
He's hurt.
I have my ult.
Swapping to Sue.
E back.
Yeah, okay.
On top, on top.
On the point.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I have charge.
We're fine.
Wolf down.
Nice, nice, nice.
Cap dead.
Sing, Sing, Sing.
Nice, nice, nice.
Easy win.
Easy.
What a dude.
Such a wipe this time.
It's because we figured out our comp.
Against this team.
I think Groot just fucked us up.
Yeah.
To beat the tiebreaker...
Groot just do it so well and everything explodes.
It's awful.
So to beat the tiebreaker, we have to stomp the other team hard.
This is performance based.
Okay.
Well, who are we against though?
We don't know until later, right?
Yeah.
Bro, oh my god.
Damn.
Nothing, I'm just looking at it.
I keep forgetting Loki can do good damage too.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
The game before when we both went into overtime, all the healers had like 20k.
Did the tiebreaker put us into winners?
Or is that during the losers?
Huh?
Like the tiebreaker.
The tiebreaker would put us into winners.
So we have to stomp the last team.
If we stomp the last team...
Uh...
We don't do losers.
Yeah.
We actually stomped them this time.
It was even close when they had the minute advantage, which is crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
It's because we just figured out our comp at the last minute.
We're actually good.
We're actually good at the game.
Hold on a second.
Yeah.
I think like attack, we were brute forcing some comps in.
So we have to be more proactive on swapping.
Yeah.
Scouting, yeah.
Do we...
Wait, wait, where did...
I was like DC for a second.
I left the comps.
I'm trying to read.
Uh...
Because they said there will be no tie breakers.
So I guess like, if it's performance based, we just have to do really, really well against the last team.
Because we're still one.
We're still number one at the moment.
Am I dipping out?
That's the plan.
We'll see who we're playing against.
Because we're playing against a hard team.
Or we're playing against them again.
I think we need to run you as our 3-3.
I just realized Kony got the MVP last game.
Yeah.
Kony, okay.
Kony might be the thing.
Let me screenshot this real fast.
Sorry, I was in the bathroom.
Yeah, I got MVP.
Just so everybody knows.
Just to make that clear.
So we gotta like...
I don't know if we play against them again.
Because of the fact that...
They're doing switch bracket.
Yeah.
It depends on if any other team went...
What?
5-1?
Because we went 5-1.
They went 5-1.
If there are two more 5-1 teams, then maybe.
But if not, we play them again.
I would imagine.
Yeah.
But here's the thing.
Like...
Dude, I'm fucked up.
I really think that...
If they're threatened by this comp.
Because this is a really good comp against them.
They don't know what to do because they're cheesing.
Yeah, yeah.
Definitely.
So they're gonna leave something open for us.
If they wanna focus ban one of our good tanks.
We get Starlord or we get Luna.
Yeah, we get Luna or Starlord.
That's also really good for us too.
Yeah.
We're just gonna keep banning Rocket and Groot.
Because that's the main part of their cheese.
The overload ammo and the walls and all that shit.
Yup.
Okay.
Adam was definitely a really good pick there.
For sure.
Yeah, the Soulbond helped a lot.
Gave me enough time to shift.
To save some people as well.
See how OP the Korean comps are.
That shit was crazy.
Three tank.
We've made a loop.
Back.
Back here again.
I'm not exactly thrilled about that.
Aww.
Which team are we waiting on?
We're waiting on one more team.
And then it should be good.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
When's the next game?
Do we know?
Hello?
In like three minutes.
Okay.
I think it's just waiting for the other group to finish, right?
Or the other teams to finish.
Yep.
Alright.
Hello chat, hello.
Oh shit, I'm not muted.
Hi.
Hello chat.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm back chat.
I muted myself.
I was happy.
My item was really good.
During that game.
I was really worried.
Because like...
I don't know.
I was just really worried.
Yeah.
My item was bad.
I was making really good decisions on item.
And stuff.
I don't play item that much.
So I was just like, oh thank god.
I was like...
Yeah.
Because on item.
It's more of a mind game.
On item.
I have to be aware of my...
Of my cooldowns.
I have to be aware of my cooldowns.
And my abilities.
So I have to make decisions on whether or not to use soul link.
And everything.
And also my snaps too.
Because I can't build ult that fast.
With healing.
Because I don't want to waste my snaps.
On situations where my other two healers can heal.
So like...
And I have to know when to ult.
So the moment when Gomez got picked.
I instantly went for the ult.
Because I was like...
Our comp needed all of us to be alive.
So...
The moment we got picked.
I just had to ult.
And just try to find a place.
And I was happy I was hitting shots too on Adam.
Because his projectiles are pretty difficult.
His projectiles are like...
I haven't done his projectiles in a long time.
Because I don't play...
Adam is such a...
Character that...
It's harder to play in high elo.
And usually a better support player would play...
Adam in one above all.
So I would just be placed on...
I would either be on Luna duty.
Or Sue duty.
And then the better player would be on Adam.
So...
Yeah.
So it was like...
I didn't get a chance to practice Adam a lot.
Yeah, my voice is fucked right now.
Because I talked a lot.
Yeah.
I'm just glad I made good calls for a so long too.
Because...
That one was the riskiest shit.
Where the fuck did I put my Kleenex?
Kleenex.
I'm gonna blow my nose.
I opened one...
Today.
I know I opened one today.
Where did it go?
Did I put it away?
I'm gonna blow my nose.
I'm gonna open a new one.
I'll be back.
I'm gonna open a new pack of tissues.
I'm gonna feed Doki Amber Doge real quick, guys.
Give me a sec.
Yeah, I'm back.
I'm back.
Feed him real quick.
I do hope...
If we win Winners Bracket...
Then...
I can walk him in time.
That's really it.
But yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just happy we won that fight.
See, Mortal Rivals is all about figuring out the team comps too.
It doesn't matter how good your team is individual wise.
Comps still counter you and stuff like that.
Definitely our weakest point right now is...
We're not proactive when we're swapping comps.
Which I told Gomez.
If you think this comp isn't working...
Just call for the swap.
Don't force it.
Yeah, because they were hard countering us at first.
But the moment we figured out the comp...
Because when we figured out the comp...
They didn't know what the fuck to do.
Because of it.
They didn't know what to do when we figured out how to counter them.
Um...
They already put the next team that we're playing against.
I'll give you the code.
The thing is, do we run Betel first or Jay first?
We'll do a reversal now.
We'll put Betel in and then we'll put...
Jay later?
Okay.
I'll give you the ID.
I'll tell...
We're running...
We are running Betel first.
I'll give you the UID too.
Let me scout this team out real fast.
So this is our tiebreaker team?
Yeah, we have to stomp them basically.
They have a Lord Bucky.
A Lord Bucky.
Um... Namor.
Strange.
They're running Strange.
Uh... Mag.
They're running different comps every time.
But they do have a Storm player too.
Do we just want to ban Bucky?
Yeah, I mean...
Their Bucky is...
Yeah, their Bucky is their best player.
Wait, let me double check.
Uh...
Yeah, their Bucky plays hella Bucky.
Actually, no.
Their Namor is their best player.
Their Namor has more kills, but...
Their Bucky has more damage.
They banned Jeff?
Wait, what?
Oh wait, they did.
I guess they played against a Jeff player.
I mean, one of them seems like a Namor...
Specialist too.
So I don't know.
They run a bunch of comps, but it's only Bucky.
So we just ban Bucky then?
I don't see no Groot, so I don't think they played Groot.
Has any team like pulled out ahead with all like twos?
No.
There's a four-team tie for first.
Yeah.
If we stomp them and get two-two, then we win the tiebreaker.
We just need to stomp them and win two.
It has to be a big stomp to win the tiebreaker.
Alright, what's the tiebreaker map?
There's no tiebreaker map, but like...
We have to stomp this team.
Because it's performance-based.
So which one is this?
This one is...
Shibuya...
Shibuya Convergence.
Wait, is this round four or five?
This is round...
Round four.
Oh wait, it's round four.
Oh, okay.
It's Hall of...
I guess we have to stomp two teams then.
Nevermind, we have two more rounds.
I didn't see the...
I did not see the round five at the end.
Cause I had to move it.
Um, Hall of...
Uh, Hall of T'Challa.
I don't know how to pronounce it.
It's Convergence.
T'Challa!
From Wakanda!
So their last fight was...
They ran Strange Mag, Bucky, Namor, Cloak and Dagger, and Luna.
So we just ban Bucky first and see what they do after.
And then we protect Mag.
Alright.
Best player is the Namor.
Alright, are we all ready?
Yeah, we're ready.
Alright.
We're going in.
Starting right away.
Are we running 2-2-2 first?
Or just go off the bad line?
Good.
We can do 2-2-2 first.
I shine in darkness.
Okay, Coney.
Coney on the Spider-Man.
I got something special!
Oh, I believe.
Ah, wow!
I saw that one coming.
Wow!
I can't believe it.
Uh, Bucky.
Ban Buck.
And then protect Mag.
Wait, what if we protect Luna?
Or no, they want the team up.
Yeah, they want the team up.
Yeah, it's in our benefit to get Mag.
Yeah, because they have a Namor player.
I mean, we can fuck them over and just ban Luna and I'll just play...
I'll play something else.
I'll see you.
And we really want to fuck up their Namor.
But the Namor also plays Storm and Hela.
That's the thing.
Oh, it's fine.
Wait, no one fucked up both of those guys.
What fucks up both their comps?
Uh, the other character that would fuck up their comp would be...
Oh, they did.
They banned their own Luna.
They banned Luna.
We could ban Storm.
Do you think they'll choose and try to go Groot?
Um, no.
Have they played Groot?
No.
Should we just ban Storm?
I'm just gonna ban Storm.
We didn't struggle.
We never struggle against Roverian, really.
I think so.
We're fine.
I think just ban Storm and get that out.
Alright.
We'll do...
So, we're kind of forced on the...
I mean, we can just do this again.
We could.
We could just pull this out.
We kind of dominated on it, to be honest.
Fuck it.
Let's do it again.
What was that team that fucked our 3-3's over?
What did they play that fucked it over?
They ran both...
No, not Storm.
They ran Squirrel and Moon Knight.
Squirrel, Moon Knight, right.
Okay, so the moment they swap to Squirrel and Moon Knight, we just swap comms.
Okay.
That's if they do it, though.
I don't want to give that away.
Like, they might not even know.
We saw it on stream.
How lucky.
They're gonna do it now.
I mean, they've been...
They can just watch the VOD later.
So, if it's like, they have both Moon Knight and Squirrel or just both of them, or just one.
I think it's both of them.
Both of them fucked us over.
I don't think they have a Squirrel girl, though.
If they run Moon Knight, Groot, we swap off 3-3.
Okay, by the way, we're gonna do something because I do this in scrims.
Okay, so come here.
They're gonna portal.
No, I know exactly what you're talking about.
I've done it before.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
No, no, not there.
By me.
By my portal.
By the portal.
We're just gonna shoot Strange.
Strange will get blasted if they try to TP.
Okay, are they TPing?
If they don't.
Let's see.
They're walking up.
I'm just looking.
Maybe they do a walk-up TP?
They're still walking through main.
They're walking through main.
I'm gonna put TP right now.
They're going through high.
Shoot them.
You can break the wall.
You can break that huge wall right there.
They're looking at... They're heading up.
They're heading up now.
They're running Moon Knight.
Run over.
Fly on me.
Me and you stay up here.
Try not to take too much damage.
Moon Knight one.
Strange low.
Don't peek too much.
Jesus, that did a lot.
We have to play together like last time.
I have to link us.
I'm linking us.
Strange low.
We're up two.
We're up one actually.
We're good.
We're killing.
Let's walk up.
Good job.
Walk up the mag.
Nice!
I'm bad.
I got blown the fuck up.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Right there.
Behind us.
If you do it, let me jump you.
I got you.
I'm low.
It's big.
Strange on me.
That's fine.
Strange.
I got him.
Get the mag.
Good job.
They might have their support ults.
They're going to have support ults.
I'll try and slow on us.
I have ult for cloak and dagger.
Skeleton figure left.
I'm looking.
I'm invisible.
You should scout line.
I'm just sitting.
They're coming.
Hella here.
Go back to me.
They're wolf.
Hella's on the left.
I'm going left side.
I'll mark her.
Wolf here.
He's trying to come in.
He stopped.
Right there.
Wolverine very low.
He couldn't do anything.
I'm keeping my soul bond.
I have ult up.
Just hold the front line.
And then I just go and hold the off angle.
I'll ult first.
Right here.
Nice.
I have ult though.
I'm ulting back.
Is it worth rezzing?
No, it's not.
I'm not going to use it.
No, I'm fine.
Got it.
Nice.
Good ult.
Good shit.
They switched to Punisher.
They're running one tank now.
You can break that wall?
I've never seen that.
That's crazy.
They don't do it in Diamond, I guess.
Grandmaster, thank you.
Come here.
They're going to come here.
Get Punisher.
I'll hold this with him.
I'm going to drop and do a flank to you, okay?
I'm low.
Right here?
He stopped.
Wolf missed.
Never mind.
I soul bonded us.
So we should win.
Okay, never mind.
Not me, I guess.
Oh, no.
Nice play.
Huge.
Fuck yeah.
I got double ulted there.
I got Mag fucking rocked.
And then Wolverine ulted.
I was like, that soul bond is not fucking saving me.
Wow, dude.
I had that all game.
I hadn't had to use it yet.
I didn't get to use my rez.
I feel disgusting.
This doesn't feel good.
Gomez, you need that.
You need to get to your tournament in time.
I think we just portal.
I put my clones behind.
You guys flood in.
I just keep healing you guys.
And they can't do anything about that.
And you just flood in.
I follow after.
I'll soul link after your immortal is gone then.
I'll shift first into the portal.
You shift first, and then I'll soul link after.
Alright, got it.
Uh oh, only ult.
I can only do this as Luna.
Wait, check this out.
Oh, fuck.
Wait.
Somebody get up there, I'll jump to you.
Wait a minute.
Rocket's not bad, we can get armor pack right now.
Oh.
Wait.
Do it, do it, do it.
You're breaking your own code.
You're breaking the team code.
I don't want to be losers bracket, guys.
I'm going to cut off my hands after this tournament.
He can't get it.
I'm swapping in 3, 2, 1.
I'm going to walk up.
I'm going to walk up just to make sure they don't TP play.
And I just wasted my jump.
Okay.
Are we not TPing?
We are, we are, we are.
We walk up and TP.
They're on high ground, and TPing.
Get on there.
I go on.
So linked, you guys can push up if you want to.
Yeah.
Okay, we wait a little bit.
Can we get them?
There's a rocket revive thing.
She's behind, she's 1.
Okay, we just push it.
Push the front line.
Nice job.
Hello 1.
I'm dropping on point right now.
Yeah, I have shift.
Yeah, we're just in.
Okay, Punisher, Punisher dead.
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
Mag's the one contesting point.
We're on the healers right now.
Okay, let's get it.
Good job.
Let's go.
Is that what we needed?
Yeah, we just keep running this comp.
Oh, we're watching in this comp.
Oh boy.
Good shit.
Ghosts are back!
Yay!
At least there's no Brig stunned.
Yeah.
Do we put Jay or just run Beto throughout for this comp?
I'll see you.
It's your call.
It's your call, Gomez.
You're the IGL.
This is your team.
You know more than me.
Okay, but you pick this team.
But you know more.
What would stomp this team more?
Because we need a Brig.
I think we keep it as it is.
Because if it's working this well, just don't...
Let's keep it this for now.
Because if this is life or death, losers are winners.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll let Jay know.
I'm staying?
Yeah, you're staying for this one.
Yeah, you're not going to get put in the streets.
Not yet.
Okay, let me see.
What's the next one?
Hell's Haven.
Gross.
You don't like Hell's Haven?
No.
Really?
Oh, never mind.
I forgot you're a tank player.
You just get pulled off every tank battle.
I need to take a screenshot.
It's okay, we have the history.
Or whenever.
What's my stats for this?
It's alright.
Okay.
That's crazy.
One loss and we have a chance of going to losers bracket.
Yeah.
What?
That's insane.
Yeah.
Not even a full stat loss, just a single game.
They're ready.
Alright, cool.
Oh, this map, Namor is really good in.
But, they seem...
I don't know if they're going to ban Luna again this time.
Yeah.
I mean, we can just ban Luna and fuck over them.
I mean, if they don't protect Luna, we just ban her.
Sorry, sorry.
They're ready, by the way.
They're ready?
Okay.
Yeah.
What was the ban line you guys were talking about?
What was it?
If they don't ban Luna, we can just ban her.
Alright.
I'm cool with that.
Cause I'd have to ban Mag or Starlord.
So, like, it doesn't matter for us.
I can do both.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we can protect Mag again.
We banned Bucky last time.
That's fine.
I just keep it with that same ban.
Did I just hear that?
Yeah, that's...
That's Gomez's?
Holy shit.
And then protect Mag.
He's a yapper.
Picked him up.
I usually have a cat cam on, but...
They're doing Moon Knight.
Should we ban Groot?
I mean, we didn't ban Moon Knight last time.
They banned Strange.
Strange dead.
They protected Moon Knight, so they might do Cheese.
Should we just ban Groot?
Sure.
Alright, yeah, fuck it.
Get Groot out.
So they can't do the combo, too.
They might try to do the Namor-Moon Knight combo.
Alright.
So they won't have two...
I'll switch back to Sue if we feel like we don't have the heals.
Yeah.
Wait, what am I on?
Are we doing...
What do you play?
We go 2-1-3?
Oh, we banned Bucky, too.
What the fuck?
We banned Bucky.
Namor?
Are you a Namor player?
Oh, no.
I don't touch that character.
Yes, you do.
He just hates Namor.
You know what?
I'll play Storm.
Storm?
Okay.
I'm just going to play in the middle of all of you, okay?
Whenever I call my ult, we just hard walk it, okay?
Wolverine is not bad.
That is true.
But Storm is super OP with this.
Do they have one or two tanks?
They have two, but they went 1-3-2 against our 3-3.
They adjusted, yeah.
Yeah, they were a strange mag at first.
You know what?
I trust them.
I'm doing it.
Do I put it on you or Coney?
Or do I pull out the fantastic?
No.
We need to stop.
You don't want to do losers bracket.
You need to stop.
Don't you need it to leave at 3, bro?
Yeah.
If your team loses the tournament because you have to do a losers bracket in a VTuber tournament, that's on you.
That's on you.
I'm waiting on you all.
They come through main.
If they come through main, I look for a pickup.
They're on main.
Okay.
Pick them up.
Keep pushing it.
Oh, they don't.
Oh, wait, bro.
Holy.
Storm's low.
That's fine.
You died for the cost, Coney.
It's all good.
No, I was in there.
I was trying to clear the whole thing.
I thought it was an Ankh, but it was Storm's hammer.
Yeah, I saw that too.
You know what?
If he comes close enough...
I saw you.
Let's just go for a cocky play.
I'm doing something here.
Oh, they're going right.
Who's on top?
Right here.
One here.
Moon Knight.
Moon one.
Jhin died to that.
I got split.
Yeah, we got split by that.
I tried to back up.
Just get me up.
Yeah, Turret's out.
Turret's out.
Watch out.
I have ult.
I'm pushing in.
I'm pushing in with it.
I got you.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Get that Thor!
There's a Thor right behind you!
See you guys.
Veno, you just let that Thor have it.
Giving you back shots.
He was literally giving you back shots when I was watching it.
Thank you for coming back for me, DonQ.
I was so scared.
Here, I pull him in.
Coney, Coney.
Actually, hold on.
You want to do something that I do with Hogs?
I'm going to fly in and then you ult them, okay?
Ready?
Not yet.
Oh, not yet?
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh, I'm going to die.
I was saying it wasn't us yet!
My bad.
The Thor should die.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm going to keep you guys back here alive.
Okay, it's done, it's done.
Thor, Thor, Thor!
Just look for Rez here.
Kill the invisible.
No, cloak.
Fucking white women.
Get ready for Rez!
Rez, Rez, Rez!
Their clothes!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I got you, I got you, I got you!
Guys, it's big.
It always is.
Lime just fucking took me out of that.
I was like, what the fuck?
I always confuse her with an invisible woman because they're both wearing white with blonde hair.
She's not playing around.
Sorry for stun locking you a little bit.
Guys, it's okay, we won.
Holy fuck.
That was wild.
Fucking white woman.
Lime does not represent the team, I have to disclaimer.
If you have any complaints, please direct it to Limealicious on Twitch.
I thought you threw, bro.
I told you my ult wasn't up.
Okay, Coney.
Just throw me out of spawn here, okay?
You have the freedom to just throw me.
I'll throw you and jump to you.
So go far left since we're running this comp.
Yeah, just throw me right here.
Like this?
Okay, well...
I didn't know how heavy you were!
Don't do this a lot!
They have Hawkeye, by the way.
Hawkeye, Storm.
I did not mean to go up this much.
Careful of Storm one shots.
Look for my grabs here, okay?
You ready?
Oh, actually.
Got him, got him, got him.
Look at him, look at him.
I'm scratching him.
I'm ulting this.
This is actually a hydrogen bomb right now.
Holy shit!
Here's our hydrogen bomb.
Oh my god.
Shouldn't have banned Starlord.
Yeah, shouldn't have banned Starlord.
Did he break this right here?
Yeah, yeah.
We don't break the whole thing.
We break the top so he can stand on top of it next time.
Yeah, yeah, just break the top.
There's a Thor on the right.
One here, one here.
He's stuck.
He's scared.
I don't have leap.
Thor to the left, Thor to the left.
I don't have...
You copy me whenever.
I'm doing it now.
Walking hard.
I got moonlighted.
I'm healing now.
I'm still healing.
Starlord should be 1HP.
I'm looking.
I got moon.
Nice, good job.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got ult up for this next one.
Alright.
I'm gonna go high ground now.
I got ult for cloak and dagger.
I'm too fucking short.
I can't make this fucking jump.
Fucking Wolverine debuff.
Here, Coney, we can do the thing here.
Alright, let's get it.
Let's go.
Oh my god, we missed.
Oh god.
I'm fucking dead.
I got one.
You got this, you got this.
Just hit him, just hit him.
Nice, good job, good job.
Got the invisible one.
I clobbered them.
We just clobbered them.
Oh yeah, Wolverine is 5 foot 4.
5 foot 4 problems.
That was the stomp you want.
That was literally 100-100.
We have to stomp the next one.
I think we have another round too.
So we gotta stomp another one too.
I guess the same guys are different people.
I don't know, we gotta see what...
We see how they win their games.
Because if there's another team that won all their games except for one tiebreaker then we fight them.
Okay, let me...
Because if there isn't, I believe we might fight the same team then.
Okay.
Alright.
I put it in our score.
Nice.
We're doing good.
We're adapting.
We are doing pretty good.
We're adapting guys.
I don't wanna say it.
Don't jinx us.
We're doing fantastic.
Say that again.
Let's see.
Are they fighting?
Oh shit!
Wait!
Oh!
The...
The Oni inmates lost one game to one of their...
to the mission windows.
So we're up one point against them.
Cool.
We have to stomp round 5 too.
We will.
Then we get the winner's bracket.
Alright.
I got a pee break.
I'll be right back.
Am I leaving?
We should probably swap now, right?
Yeah.
If that works.
Whatever you guys wanna do.
I'm always down to just keep playing, but Jay's in prison.
No, Jay.
Jay, no.
They're mopping out their sentences.
I can't believe Rebels made me have to actually watch out what I say now.
I can't say okay, here's the thing.
Or I can't say fucking...
No, I think that's the only thing, right?
Fantastic.
Can't say fantastic anymore.
I guess there's a new one that's happening right now.
Soup.
I don't know.
From fucking Human Torch.
Yeah, Human Torch just says soup if he dies.
Oh, that's right.
I heard the Venom wee.
That one's pretty funny.
That one's strange.
It says bye.
I love the bye.
Bye.
I always laugh when Starlord gets dunked because his is like such a big show of everything and then no.
I hate that all.
You don't like it?
It scares me.
It's scary.
But you know what counters it?
I like it when he says legend.
I like that part.
As long as we have a support op for a Starlord ult, we counter it.
Are we the first team that finished both?
Yeah, we are.
Probably.
We are.
I'm looking at it.
Only one team has done one and then...
Yeah, everyone else is still on their second matches.
So, I think it's Cultist.
Yeah, we currently have...
We're currently have...
We're currently rank one right now in our group.
And for winner's bracket, if we win all of them and we get to winner's bracket, we fight Group G.
And Group G's best player is...
Oh, they have been undefeated.
Their best team has been undefeated so far.
I'm looking them up.
Wow.
Yeah.
What are they called?
The Schlongschlots.
If anyone wants to analyze their team later...
I'll do it.
That's my job.
This is their handles.
Let's see.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Yeah.
This is them.
That's the team that we're gonna fight.
We're winners.
Um...
Yeah, Mace's team is undefeated, by the way.
Mace's team...
I mean, we could have been undefeated.
I'm not too worried about that.
It was just like...
We just got cheesed.
Yeah.
It's all good.
Uh, wait a minute.
Wow.
Interesting.
Okay.
Trying to see if...
Oh, yeah.
Uh...
Oh!
Wait, the team that we thought was the hardest team...
They also have a tie.
They weren't undefeated.
They had one tie.
Yeah.
Who did they tie against?
That's interesting.
Tied against somebody.
Uh...
Analyzing...
Can I let Jay into the call?
Depends on which team we're fighting, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't know who we're fighting.
Because if we're fighting against the Oni people, we keep you in.
Okay.
I'm assuming... I will be right back.
Um...
I'm glad we're improving every game, Chat.
I'm gonna mess up, but I'm really happy that every game, we're just... Our team is just getting like, better and better.
So, like, I'm very happy about it.
And we're adapting really well.
So...
Yeah.
We're...
Uh... Yeah, the team, we're improving, and we're all adapting incredibly well.
A lot of teams in this tournament have been trying so hard.
They've been, like, scrimming.
Like, some teams have been scrimming every day.
But our team, obviously, like, all of us are incredibly busy people, too.
So, I'm happy we're able to... Everybody took it really seriously, too, on our team.
And we all, like, uh... You know, we all did, like, we did four to five scrims together before the tournament.
Uh...
And, uh...
And... And we managed to, you know, I'm glad we managed to get practice in and managed to, you know, get a feel of each other and, like, get, like, you know, cover our weaknesses before...
Cover our weaknesses and everything, uh, going in.
We still got a couple minutes, right?
Yeah, like, they haven't even finished their game yet.
Okay, cool.
I'll be right back one sec.
Yeah, yeah.
So, a lot of teams are still fighting.
Um... But, yeah.
I'm just... I'm just happy.
And, you know, my first couple of games I was super... I'm more comfortable right now.
I'm more comfortable and, like, my first couple of games, I definitely made a lot of mistakes.
I was...
I mean, I made a lot of mistakes.
I'm not...
I'm not, like... I'm not tired.
I've hit my second win.
I've definitely hit my second win now.
So, like, I'm okay now.
I...
I also didn't warm up going in.
Like, the first game was my fucking warm up game.
Um...
But, yeah.
I'm just... I'm just happy with how well we're doing so far.
I'm gonna check if we are playing four or five teams.
Because, like, I'm so confused.
I'm...
I'm a little... Okay, yeah.
Round... Wait, is it round five?
Okay, match five.
Okay, we do play five teams.
Oh, okay.
I wonder who we play against.
Uh...
Yeah, I was...
I was nervous as fuck starting.
But, because it's always, like, you know, the first... the first tournament always makes me incredibly... Like, it's my first actual Marvel Rivals tournament, so I'm so fucking...
I'm so nervous.
But, I'm now... I'm definitely more comfortable.
I'm definitely getting more comfortable now.
Also, why swapping out?
Um, Beto was originally gonna be on day two only.
And, um, so, but, uh, the thing he was gonna do on the...
but then something that he could... he could come in day one.
And so, like, because the thing he was gonna do on day one got rescheduled.
And we swapped between the two because Beto and Jay are both...
because, like, Beto and Jay are both special specialists on different tanks.
So, if, like, Beto is getting hard-targeted banned, we'll swap in Jay because, like, Jay has, like, a different hero pool than Beto.
And so, like, that's why...
Yeah, and then Coney's hero pool overlaps with both Beto and Jay.
So, like, we could keep Coney.
We just have to swap between Beto and Jay.
So, like, they can't analyze our team that well.
So, like, during day two it's harder to analyze our team because, like, we don't know which tank we're gonna put in.
So, like, if we want to put in... Obviously, if we want to put in, like, a strange player, we'll put in Jay.
But we want to put in, like, you know, like, Jay...
Not just strange, but he basically plays the heroes that Beto doesn't play.
And then Beto plays... Yeah, we can do that.
We can swap subs.
We can swap players in between matches.
Because tournaments have that too.
That's why, like, in the official tournaments you'll see teams.
They'll have, like, specialists and stuff for certain characters.
So, like, if they want to swap, like, maybe, like, what team?
The European team that won first.
I forgot.
I know they're signed to...
They're signed to Virtus.pro I think now.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
But the EU team that won the MCR, they have several specialists.
So they have, like, you guys don't know...
You guys remember Healus?
He's on that team.
And he's their Wolverine magic specialist.
So they're trying to run comps for, like, you know, they're trying to run comps that require Wolverine or magic.
Healus gets put in as their, like, specialist and stuff like that.
So, like, a lot of, like, hero shooters have that.
Because no one person can cover all characters.
Like, it's that it's so difficult to be, like, the best at every single character in your role.
So...
So, yeah.
So, like, it's good to have players to cover your weakness.
Originally, originally Beto was supposed to only play on day 2 but since he could come on day 1 then, like, obviously why don't we take advantage of that, you know?
Like, the fact that we could have two tank players rotate.
We might as well take advantage of that.
Yeah.
Like, obviously I could try and play as many supports as possible.
But, like I said, Adam's not my best support.
But, like, I can still play him in my rank.
I just, you know, I'm basically the Luna specialist on my team.
But I can still swap in between other roles if needed.
Because, like, so they can't target ban me.
Like, you know, like...
Who thought of this?
Was it you?
I mean, when Beto said that he could come on day 1 I was just like, we'll just rotate tanks.
We'll just rotate tanks so day 2 would be harder for people to analyze us.
Because we can play different comps.
Like, we actually didn't, we haven't pulled out a comp that we practiced on scrims yet.
There's one comp we haven't pulled.
Like, I mean, there's two comps we haven't pulled out yet.
So, like, because, like, obviously we don't need to pull it out.
We don't need to use it yet.
But yeah, no, this tournament was a lot sweatier.
I mean, I knew it was going to be really sweaty.
I knew it was going to be incredibly sweaty.
But, like, this tournament was definitely more sweaty than I expected.
It was more sweaty than I actually expected it to be.
I'm having fun.
No, it's competitive and competitive is always really fun.
It's always really, really fun.
I just get way too competitive, though.
That's, like, my biggest fault, is that I get way too competitive during these.
So you can tell I'm, like, more serious and stuff.
I still, like, try to make jokes every so often, but I'm just a very competitive person in general.
So I get, like, super focused and everything.
Yeah, and also, like, I know that because I'm considered, like, you know, like, the higher, like, me and Gomez are both the high rankers on our team.
Also, where's the leaderboard right now?
Am I, like, still safe?
I am.
Okay.
I need to play rank soon, because, like, it says that I haven't played rank in four days, so I need to play rank, like, either today or tomorrow.
I hope I don't get dropped.
No, I can play tomorrow.
So, like, if I do lose that, I don't want to lose my one above all.
I don't want to keep my one above all.
I don't want to lose it during... I don't want to lose it for day two.
I'll just do it tomorrow.
I'll just do it after the tournament tomorrow.
No, yeah, if you're in Eternity, there's rank decay.
So, yeah.
I haven't been playing a lot on my main, though.
Just because I'm very busy and everything.
I've been too busy.
I've been playing on my ult accounts, just because, like, I don't want to try too hard.
So I just play on my ults.
What's my second favorite strategist after Luna?
Um...
None of them.
I don't really... I don't know.
I like Luna's kit the most.
The other support supports I play just because, like, just because I have to.
Just, like, because it's, like, support meta.
I know why I say I hate the most Rocket.
I got cut off my hands after this tournament because I fucking tainted myself.
I think Luna's kit is the most fun out of all of the characters so far.
Unless Professor Xavier is...
When Professor Xavier comes out, he's gonna be my second favorite.
Who the hell is Super Gooner?
And Ultra Cool Sigma.
What the fuck?
Wait, who are these guys?
It's open to all!
Oh my god!
Gomez!
What the hell, bro?
How did they get in?
Who leaves the couch?
You should sub someone out for that guy.
Super Gooner, man.
Oh, wow.
I was like, oh, those are our opponents.
Yeah, I was like, what?
Super Goony?
I got scared.
I was getting ready to fight that guy.
There's no fighting Super Gooner.
No!
Yeah, it's already too late.
We've already lost.
He has nothing to lose.
Has every team...
One team's finished.
One team's done with their games.
So we stomped hard.
Yeah, but we gotta stomp the next one.
If we have only one tie, then we're Winner's Bracket.
Omni has two ties.
We don't know if they have two ties.
I think Omni and Mission are over time right now.
They haven't posted their results yet.
I have no idea.
Yeah, Winner's Bracket is day two.
If we get Loser Bracket, we have to keep going.
If we get Winner's Bracket, we're set.
We're set for tomorrow.
And then tomorrow, we fight Group G, where their team has not lost a single game yet.
So, it is a little scary that their team hasn't lost a single game for Group G.
But Gomez and I are going to research, look at VODs and see what they play.
Because I knew, before we fought Omni, I told my team, I was like, this is a team that might take a point off of us.
They could be the hardest.
Their rank average was the highest out of everybody.
Because I looked through the day before the tournament.
I took notes of all the teams in our group, and I knew that team had the highest rank average, so it would pose the biggest threat for us.
No, their rank average was Celestial.
They had a Celestial high GM rank average.
And for us, obviously, ours is like, there's me and Gomez at one above all, but our players aren't Celestials.
Our players are GM.
So, as a team, and I think their team screamed a lot too.
No, you don't.
No, they'll...
No, you don't!
What if they're gonna put fucking weird-ass...
No, you don't.
You are not risking our streams.
Fuck.
I won't do it.
Yeah, we might have a funny...
We might have had Super Gooner, but we don't know what's next after that.
I feel like Super Gooner is pretty tame compared to what could be.
Yeah, what could be?
Like...
It's basically like, hey, do you want our streams to get privated?
Especially Betel.
Oh, yeah.
Betel might get...
Betel's the one that definitely will get privated.
Okay, we'll keep it safe then.
We'll keep it safe.
Alright.
I'm like looking at it, but nobody's posted screenshots.
Jesus Christ.
These streams are like long.
I'm gonna get water, guys.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back.
Oh, someone's asking what One Above All is.
Yeah, One Above All is Top 500.
I'm currently Top 500, but I don't play a lot on my main, though.
I think I only have...
I have...
I played 187 games in Season 1.0, but that's not a lot in Top 500.
That's actually...
That's actually not a lot compared to other people.
So like, I mean, you can see they have 415 wins and all that shit.
I have like 114 wins, so like I don't really have a lot of...
Oh, that's Iremix.
That's an alt account.
But...
I don't think I got as a lot of games as...
I don't like these people.
Usually people have more games played here.
But yeah.
But like, this season I have not played a lot.
This season, I've literally just played one game.
I have played one game.
Yeah.
No, the first season, this one, this was hell, because I had to climb all the way from the bottom.
But like, you know, like...
There's no...
There's not actual rank...
I had to go from bronze to...
And then like, every ELO are all good players.
Like, when you first started out, every ELO was very...
Like, you know, Plat was considered top 500.
Diamond was considered top 500.
That shit was so difficult.
When he fell off, I fucking won my one game.
I technically have 100% win rate.
What the fuck do you mean?
But yeah, I haven't played on main.
I've just been playing on my ulti counts.
Just cause like...
Because of this tournament, cause I like looking at one above all when I'm playing.
Cause that's just my ego.
It's... Okay, I'll say.
It's because of my ego, guys.
I like to see myself have the one above all under my name in the custom lobby.
So I haven't... I haven't played... I haven't played any ranked games on my main, cause I wanted to keep... I wanted to keep it for the tournament.
I...
I wanted to flex it, okay?
I just wanted to flex it.
I'm so real for that.
I mean, I got targeted, Ben.
They literally banned...
It's like me and Gomez are getting banned, cause they're banning my Luna.
But the thing is, I can adapt.
I can adapt to other supports.
And we like practice for when our Luna gets banned.
But yeah.
What am I acting on?
What happened?
I think one team... One team has overtime or some shit.
Oh.
Cause I'm looking at the brackets and... and Group B has already started their fourth round.
Yeah.
Like...
Oh, every other group has started their fourth round.
Yeah.
No, they're doing...
Wait, how could they be... Oh, I guess like the first... Wait, how could they be overtime?
It's domination!
Wait!
Wait a fucking minute!
Yeah, so I'm like...
So I'm like confused.
Have we just been sitting here for no reason?
No, they haven't...
No, the... the Omni team has not yet... The Omni team hasn't finished their matches yet.
That's the only team that hasn't posted screenshots.
I'm literally looking at it.
What if they forgot?
I mean...
Then they're stupid.
I don't fucking know.
Wait, wait,
wait.
No, I got target banned in one above all lobbies.
These people would be like...
They have... I had...
I had someone... I won't say who.
But I had like one or two people on their streams.
When I played against them, they were like, they have a Luna one trick.
Bad Luna.
I was like, what do you mean?
I play other supports?
What the fuck?
And then Luna got banned.
I was like, what do you mean?
I still won the game.
I mean, I lost one of the target banned, but I won the other target banned.
I won the other target...
It's 1-1.
My record is 1-1 when I got target banned.
They were talking about me.
They named me specifically.
I was like, no!
That's not true!
Stop!
That's not true.
They won their...
They won their game.
Omni won, so they're tied.
They have two ties, so we can't tie the next one.
Oh, okay.
We'll be fine.
They have two ties right now.
I think that was the team we're waiting on.
I'm pretty sure every other team is done.
I don't understand.
How did they go overtime?
It's domination.
That one I don't know.
That's weird.
They probably went like 99-99 through all three maps.
Maybe the 99 was like 20 years long.
Or some shit.
Some intense game.
Yeah.
Alright.
Aren't we just waiting for us?
Oh my god.
No, okay, group B is still waiting.
No, only group C is playing.
Group C is the only one.
Oh, group C, F...
Yeah, group C and F went on to the next one.
Alright.
They should give us our challenge soon.
Yeah.
On Monday, I'm taking a break.
I'm doing rest days on...
Monday and...
Tuesday.
Just to fix my voice.
Because it's not good.
It is not okay.
But yeah, Monday and Tuesday I'm definitely taking a rest day.
And then we have another Marble Rivals tournament on...
What's it?
13th?
Is that Saturday?
Oh shit, it's Thursday.
Okay, let me...
I have another Marble Rivals...
I have the Toast Marble Rivals tournament.
On Thursday, I believe.
Yeah.
So...
Yay, Marble Rivals.
Yay.
Yeah,
I did.
I posted my results instantly.
Don't worry, guys.
I did my job.
Did I?
Don't worry, guys.
I definitely did my job.
Okay, who are we playing?
Come on.
Update our challenge.
Oh, this will be our last two games.
If we win.
If we are winners bracket.
Finals is definitely scary.
I don't know how many matches we're playing in finals.
I don't remember.
Okay, it doesn't say how many...
I need to read rules.
I need to read so many rules.
Wait, not every...
Wait, what the fuck?
Let's see.
There's no way.
There's no way that we have to wait for...
Do we have to wait for them too?
There's like two teams that haven't finished yet.
I think.
Wait, no.
No, this team finished.
How about this other team?
Shit, don't tell me that team hasn't...
I'm looking.
This was an hour ago.
Oh, okay.
Both teams...
Okay, everybody's done.
So our thing should be done soon.
Wait, why didn't they update us?
Where's our update?
We finished too fast that they forgot about us?
Hahaha.
Our challenge hasn't updated yet.
They haven't updated our challenge.
Maybe I'll be like...
I'll message and be like...
Hey...
Wait,
I'm checking if they updated.
They don't have it.
We noticed our challenge...
hasn't been updated yet.
Challenge...
Yeah, we were the first team to finish both sets.
One team...
First place team in their group...
goes to winners bracket.
Second place goes to losers bracket.
I don't want to play losers bracket.
I don't want to play.
When we play losers bracket, we have to play...
like...
God, how many games do we have to play?
Like...
We have to play...
1, 2, 3, 4.
We have to play 4 more matches.
We have to play 4 different teams.
That's 8 more games.
I do not want to play 8 more games, guys.
I'm not strong enough for that.
We have to stomp.
We have to hard stomp the next round.
To make sure...
we don't have to go through that.
Competitive Rivals...
takes so much out of you.
Because it's a lot.
Because I'm like...
co-IGL.
I'm also the ult tracker...
for our team.
It takes so much.
I have to think a lot.
And shit like that.
So I'm like...
I'm like...
I'm tired.
Because I don't have to do that in regular rank.
Because I don't fucking care.
I don't care as much...
in regular rank to ult track.
I mean, I ult track to myself.
But I don't talk to people.
I don't care enough.
But obviously here...
I have to actually talk.
I'm going to tell you guys what's going on.
So you guys can learn from me.
Wait, what?
Oh, because I was like...
How are we 4th place?
But they didn't put our scores in yet.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, wait a minute.
How are we 4th place?
We lost...
Our score hasn't been put yet.
They haven't put our scores in.
Yeah, I'm not here to think, guys.
I'm not here to think.
I'm here to just survive.
Wait!
Gomez!
The...
That team that we thought was really hard...
Is 3rd place right now.
In their group.
Gomez?
Oh, okay.
I guess everybody left.
I'll talk to you guys.
Fuck that guy.
I thought you guys would respond to that.
3rd place?
I'm looking at it.
And that team that we struggled with the most...
They tied 2 sets.
The team that we thought was the hardest...
In the tournament, they tied 2 sets.
So 2 teams...
Got a tie off of them.
Wait, really?
So they might be...
I'm not worried.
We did kind of overestimate them.
Because as soon as we won the 3-3 comp, they just didn't know.
Yeah, but it's also more so...
The comp-wise...
Because we know what comp goes good against them.
But if they don't make it to the finals...
We have to figure out...
We might actually play against Mace's team then.
Yeah.
Now something.
I thought it would be them or Mace.
But like...
I don't know.
I'm looking at the 2 teams that got ties off of them.
And I'm surprised.
Oh boy.
So then it might be a lot harder than we thought.
Ooh.
Well, do we know if we're going to go against one of the better teams that beat the team that we thought?
Are we going to go against them?
No, they're going to fight Mace's team.
Oh, okay.
We're playing the team that got...
We're playing the team that got a point off...
A tie off of...
Oni.
Okay.
Oh, it's casted by the way.
It's going to be casted.
It's casted?
I'll give you the group ID.
Alright, that's the leader.
That's the captain.
Alright, let me see if they hide their shit.
Let me see.
Wait, why are we playing Winner's POV?
Okay.
They do Bucky by the way.
Why are we doing Winner's POV?
We can't be playing them.
No, we're not.
We're playing a different team.
I was going to say, Winner's POV is like 08.
No, no.
We're playing against...
The Minnow.
Would I give them the right code?
Okay, I'm back again.
Wait, what?
That's not the team...
We are playing against...
Okay, hello.
Yeah, they realized it.
I'm like, we'll do it.
I'll do it.
It'll be easier.
Okay, so they do...
They sometimes play Hulk too.
They play Hulk, Strange, Bucky, Namor, and then Loki, Sue.
Alright.
I see a lot of Loki and Sue.
Wait, that's the team that we have to play?
Yeah.
They have...
Hulk, Strange, Bucky, Namor, Loki, Sue.
And then sometimes they put in Hela over Bucky sometimes.
So we ban...
Do you want to kill Bucky or save for Gomez?
Bucky is kind of just Thanos of a character.
I don't want that running around.
Oh yeah, they could use Bucky against our Loki clones.
Yeah, the Loki clone.
Let's just ban Bucky then.
Namor is not really good into double shield.
So we can leave that open.
Did you invite the people, Gomez?
I did.
Please join the cast.
They hate me.
It says join the cast.
Are we joining their room then?
Oh, I guess.
Oh, please join the...
Oh, okay.
We join their room.
Request to join.
Oh, they're you.
Oh, okay.
Can I join from one of you?
What am I doing?
I'm dumb.
We'll invite you in.
Oh, okay.
Who is missing?
Is Jay in or is it going to be Betel?
Should we put Betel first just to see how it goes?
Sure, let's do that.
Betel's in.
Who am I missing?
I'm missing Shoto.
Can't join.
I got him first.
I'm ready.
Which one's their spooker?
Like spooky dude.
Let's see.
Their best player plays Sue.
I mean, if we're just talking by rank.
Yeah, if it's rank wise.
I mean, let me look at this.
Okay.
Oh wait, Ness is in here.
It's Ness by the way, the Apex player.
Everybody's blocked except the Celestial player.
Who's the Ness?
Whoever's...
Okay, wait, let me see who their DPS is.
Let me look up.
Ness, by the way, I don't know which one's their account, but they're Apex Predator player.
I recognize Ness because I've seen him in Apex Creator Journeys.
I believe...
It's one of their DPS players.
It's either...
It's one of their DPS players that's the...
Apex player.
Okay, they play Storm.
I see Storm gameplay.
Okay.
Hella.
Jura is their other high ranker, so it's their strange player.
Jura and...
is their other high ranker.
Their highest ranker for previous seasons.
And he's their strange lord.
GM.
The other ones are like...
The other ones are like Silver, Diamond, Bronze, GM, Bronze, GM.
Should be too bad.
Wait, did we say we're ready?
Uh...
Alright, whatever.
It wasn't enough for my cat.
We back.
Oh wait, nevermind.
I don't want my cat meowing at me the entire time.
Oh, it's whatever.
They ready up.
Wait, actually, nevermind.
Oh, actually, no, I can come back in time.
Okay.
You guys can handle Bans, right?
Yeah, I mean, yeah.
Oh, they said let's go.
Okay, well, I hope we can't.
I didn't think they'd do it right away.
I hope we can't.
Did we stall?
That's fine.
We can handle Bans, I believe in us.
Alright, let's do it.
Cause we're Banning Bucky first.
We're Banning Bucky first to protect Mag.
If they don't Ban Mag.
If they target Ban Mag, we save Starlord.
Got it.
Oh, I like that.
Good.
So at least Gomez can just harass him on Starlord for fucking doing that.
And if they Ban Luna, we can play like, you know, Adam, Loki, Sue.
Oh, six minutes?
Okay.
They're like, six minutes till the game starts, apparently on the casting.
Oh, why?
I don't know.
Just in case we haven't had enough of a break for the last like 15 or 20 minutes.
I've been iced, man.
It's been like half an hour.
I'm so tired.
I'm losing my motion.
Yeah, yeah, literally.
Oh, because they're swapping casts.
They're setting up the casting.
I'm fucking using the bathroom.
I hydrated so much.
Too much gamer subs.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Let's see.
Hella Storm Strange Hulk.
They like dive That's interesting.
Do they now?
I saw like a Thor cap.
Thor cap, Hulk, that kind of stuff.
Then the last game they played like Hulk Strange and Strange Thor.
Hulk is not that scary.
Yeah.
IMO.
As long as they freeze him.
The only thing that seems consistent is like from them is a Storm, consistently a Storm player.
Oh, they're saying.
Shibuya.
Back to Shibuya we go.
Let's get it.
Alright, this could be our last two games, guys.
We got hard stomp.
Hard stomp.
There's no bans.
Oh my god.
Wait, did production do this?
Yeah.
I think so.
I like how it's only us that realize there's no debt.
I got excited.
No bans, let's go!
Okay, bye.
We all leave.
No, can we play it out?
We can have Starlord.
We can because they're doing quick play.
So we don't have the back and forth.
So we can't play it out.
Alright, invite me whenever.
19 and 32.
Damn, I've only played 32 games of competitive?
Wait, overall?
Or like this season?
No, just this season.
Holy fuck, what were you doing?
139 in season 1.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I was telling my chat that I flame people for their win rate, so I hid my stuff so they couldn't find mine.
That's...
Wow, you only have a 52% win rate?
Like yeah, man.
That's how the fucking game works.
You're in the loser queue, I see.
I didn't think loser queue was real until this game.
That is crazy.
Seriously, because I came from League and people who said that were bad.
But in this game, it's real.
Are you sure you're not coping?
I swear because I got to whatever, Diamond on Fantastic.
I was like, alright, I want to learn Starlord.
20% win rate.
Losing every game, SVP.
Just can't do anything.
It was bad.
It's real.
That's crazy.
Wait, did Coney just fucking disappeared?
Oh wait, you just cut off there.
You had like a...
They got me.
No, they got Coney.
He's talking about loser queue.
Get him, he knows too much.
They cut his internet out.
Coney, don't leave us.
I'll just be like R whenever.
I'll just write that.
Like how we didn't notice we didn't even notice it was on quick play.
We're too...
We just won it over with.
No pressure here, by the way.
I have like a 20 win rate on this map.
Hell yeah.
What?
In comp and in scrims.
This is my absolute worst map.
Why is it your worst map?
What is it that makes this your worst map?
I just don't like the map.
I just hate this map.
I was gonna say something really fucked up.
Are you gonna call me bad?
No, I was gonna say like...
Are we banning Bucky first?
Bucky, yeah.
Bucky, we don't...
They don't protect Bucky.
Star Lord or Mag, what's it gonna be?
Roll the dice.
What is it?
Namor, okay.
Can we just ban Luna?
Yeah, ban Luna.
Yeah, okay, so...
Do...
Save Mag.
And then ban Luna.
Back to triple tank.
Yay!
Woo!
Let's go!
Maybe they were thinking there's no way we ban Luna.
They didn't run Luna with their Namor.
That's the thing.
Yeah, like I looked at it and they only...
They ran...
Interesting.
They ran like...
Cause I looked and they ran Namor without a Luna, so I don't know.
Okay, so this comp is really bad at pushing this specific choke, so we're gonna just TP.
Okay.
We're gonna do a thing.
So you put your clones in first for emo and then I'll still link us later.
After.
Oh, where I'm putting us is you don't have to do that.
Oh, okay.
I'm just gonna put us like in the back so then we can rotate around and put us on high ground.
I mean, you still do the emo thing first.
I'll just like still link as soon as your emo's done.
Yep.
Do that.
Yay!
No Star Lord.
Woo!
No Star Lord!
No Luna!
Yay!
Okay, if this comp doesn't work, what do we swap to?
I'll swap to...
I can just swap to a different thing.
I can go to...
I'll probably just go Wolverine.
I'd probably go Namor if this is not working but I think Loki.
We want Loki.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, we'll just have Gomez swap then.
I'm so glad you played Loki.
I'm so glad he clicked through me.
I don't know why this character's so fun.
There's a world...
I mean, if you need to swap, I can go Strange and you can play a DPS.
Oh wait, we're insta-killing their Punisher.
Ready?
Okay.
Fucking shoot this shit.
Kill him.
Nice, I got him.
Walk up in.
Okay, we walk in.
We walk in right now.
Yep.
There it is!
Oh, I soul-linked us though.
Yeah, I'm...
I got us.
Reloading.
Cloak, cloak when you can!
Cloak!
Their Punisher's back, by the way.
Strange on me.
Strange on me as well.
Strange one!
We're good, we got it.
It's okay, don't worry.
You deal with it.
Their poor Punisher.
Dude, I went through the portal and things like turned around.
He did like a full 180.
That was weird.
I was trying to beat the shit out of that Punisher.
I just charged it up.
It was GG's for that guy.
That guy, yeah.
Oh, they're running Moon Knight.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
It's because of your controls.
Oh my god, no!
See you later, guys.
I've got the healing, don't worry.
Don't worry, I've got the snaps.
My snaps are right here.
Trinja's low, Trinja's low.
I have ult here.
I can get active.
I'm going to look for some one shots.
Oh, that's not fun.
I got you, I got you.
Now I'm waiting for a club.
Okay.
I don't know where they are.
They're right behind us.
I still linked us, I still linked us.
No way.
Yeah, I got the soul link.
Get out of here.
Good shot.
They snagged their healer ult too.
Yeah, they snagged that.
I'll have... oh, but we also don't have support.
We have Rez.
Damn!
One support push up.
One support push up, because I'll have my ult anyway.
You guys heal one of them.
I can't do anything here.
Yeah, I can't get up there.
We have soul link here?
Yeah, we do.
I got...
He's dead.
They're looking for eye.
I'm backing up there.
Nice.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
Okay.
I used my Rez early then.
I thought we would win.
We would need that.
I might just ult there.
I got ult too.
Change, change, change.
I used Rage.
Door, door, door, door.
Oh my god, I fucking died.
Door, door, door.
I got you, I got you.
This door is behind.
I'm dead.
Nice, good kill, good kill.
I was supposed to low.
I got you.
I'm just getting invisible heal.
I don't have anymore ult.
Yeah, we have to reset.
Just reset, reset.
They should have support.
They have cloak ult by the way.
So, I'll try to come in there.
This is fine.
Yeah, I used my Rez too early there.
I thought it was winnable.
Did we have Mag ult for the Punisher?
Yeah, we did.
Should I use it there?
Yeah.
But they have cloak ult, so just use it for that.
I'm going to go over here.
I'm going to do something.
I'm going to do something goofy.
I'm going behind.
I'll go with you.
Just me, just me.
Walk up.
You can walk up.
Yeah, walk up.
Give them space.
They know.
I'm going back around.
Back around.
Thor low?
No.
Okay.
Copy that.
Let's go.
Let's do it.
Sorry, I heard copy, so I thought we were low team.
I don't have it.
I did not have it.
I have ult up.
Popping it.
Oh, it's big.
Big, big, big.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I don't have...
Please focus on Thor.
Good job, good job.
Okay, my bad, my bad.
Hold on.
I forgot Lime.
I say copy in scrims whenever it comes to...
Just do mirror.
Say mirror.
I'll say mirror.
Just say mirror.
Say your name.
I'm going to say your name next time.
Alright.
I'll say the name first.
Yeah.
I want to do things though.
Oh, never mind.
I will do...
I have ult here.
I'm going to...
I'm flying up.
I'm doing the old thing.
Oh, that's what you do.
Okay, got it.
Ready?
You are.
3, 2, 1, go.
Nice, nice.
I got you.
I'm on Punisher.
Punisher 1.
I got you.
Oh, the eye.
Alright.
Portal.
It's huge.
Oh my god.
Dude, the portal too.
We want to win.
I think I messed it up.
But we have copy too.
Storm ulted?
Oh, he stopped.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
He just watched that happen.
He's just watching.
He's storm chasing.
Bro, I think...
How did he get out?
The portal ended.
No, he got out.
No, the Punisher just like...
phased through the portal.
That's crazy.
There's a small tech that no one knows at the moment.
Clearly not the Punisher.
I think the Punisher was doing it on purpose.
I think he was.
If you position your camera outside of the portal while trying to back up, the game will try to correct your position based off the portal and if it glitches out properly, then you teleport past the portal.
I watched the fucking murder.
Dude.
No, but we got the point though.
Dude, I think they needed the Luna there for what they wanted to do.
They didn't run Namor.
Yeah, they didn't run Namor at all during the first.
They just went Punisher.
Do you think they'll mirror us?
Focus on Punisher ult or Cloak and Dagger for this.
I think it's whoever's first.
If Punisher ult's first, you just fucking spike that ball.
Got it.
I'm playing from up here.
Okay.
I like to say this.
Cloak ult's not as strong as it was before where it was literally necessary to kill a Cloak every time.
So it's not really...
Portal, portal, portal.
Alright, they're gonna do that to us?
Oh, I'm gonna...
We're gonna portal too.
They're probably up here.
I'm like by myself.
Or high ground on you.
Nope, right there.
I accidentally dropped off my high ground.
That's fine.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Are you okay?
I tried to hug Strange and I jumped for Adam.
It was actually...
You landed on me.
Oh my god, they're stuck.
Yeah, they got stuck.
They didn't jump.
Oh, is it that Strange bug?
Nah, I think they just didn't commit.
They just didn't jump.
They would've died if they did, I think.
Yeah, I mean that's smart of them.
Alright, I'm dropping on them here.
Coming in too.
Jump scare.
Taking out Rocket's thing?
Okay, he dropped it.
I almost have ult here.
Thank you.
Give me this.
I'm pulling them in.
Alright, that's good.
Oh, I got them all up.
Nice.
I'm so lazy for you.
I can pull.
Rocket one.
Got it.
Oh shit, Coni!
Oh, he's one.
Alright, nice.
Alright, did they die?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should've punished ult.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Give me a jump, give me a jump.
I'm good.
I wanna ult them here.
I mean, I will let you know.
It looks so juicy.
I'll let you know.
Okay, I got it.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Oh, nice.
That was a big ult.
That's the eye.
How do you say it?
What's up?
How do you scream that?
Now I feel special.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go with...
Let's actually go aggressive here with Link.
Can we do that?
I'm gonna drop down from up here.
Infinite ammo, infinite ammo.
Watch out.
Okay, I got blown the fuck up.
They got shielded.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got blown the fuck up.
Uh oh, they disappeared too.
I can't grab 20.
Oh, I got hit.
I'm on the way.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they used everything.
I'm trying.
I got...
They don't know I'm here.
They don't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two of the supports are still alive.
I'm backing up.
I got you, I got you.
Where are you?
I'm ulting here.
Meg, meg, meg.
Got it.
Okay.
Nice recovery.
Don't lose those.
That's good, that's good.
I'm gonna save ult for Punisher.
I'm going back up top.
They might TP.
They have to TP.
Yeah, they have to.
I'm staying up here.
Oh, I just got nothing.
I'm gonna just like float above them if they try to do the same spot.
Right here.
Oh,
they faded.
Wait.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Doki coming up there.
Goodbye.
He just won the 1v1.
Wait, they're letting me build so much ult charge right now.
It's insane.
You're really gonna challenge me?
Like, really?
Bodyblock Raccoon, good shit.
I'm healing, I'm healing.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
He still wants to kill me.
Bro, that Punisher wanted to kill me so bad.
I saw the Punisher come up there, I was like, No, Doki!
And by the time I jumped, he was dead.
I, like, tried to jump up there to help.
Good shit.
One more.
Okay, the thing is, do we put Jay in for this?
Or just keep Bettle in for the 3-3?
We can put him in.
Alright.
Time for the swap.
Bye, guys.
GG's, Bettle.
GG's.
You did great, Bettle.
You were insane.
I'm gonna miss him.
Bye, Bettle.
Good shit, Bettle.
Where's Jay?
Jay's not online.
Wait, Jay went offline.
At Jay.
Oh, wait, Jay, get back on.
What happened to Jay?
Where'd he go, Jay?
Jay, boot up your game right now.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I was playing the labs.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Let me post the score thing.
Mystery.
We're really good with this comp.
You guys are killing it.
Yeah, because they keep target banning Starlord.
Yeah, and if they leave Slardar open, it's like, maybe even easier.
They're on there.
I think this comp is more about team synergy.
It's more so focused on our team play.
I agree.
Alright.
Is Jay in here yet?
Hold on, give me like 10 seconds.
Our spectators are gone.
Since we're taking a second, I'm gonna restart my game so it doesn't crash.
Oh, yeah, true.
Our casters are gone, too.
I'll just reboot.
It's been a while, so I'm due for one.
Wait, should I restart, too?
If you don't get game crashes, then don't worry about it.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Mine crashes every 5-10 games, but if I restart, it's fine.
It's like a memory leak, I guess.
It's weird.
Apparently, it's like common with the GeForce 30 series.
A bunch of people on the Reddit are like, yeah, I did this, and it doesn't work for anybody.
Did you back up your drivers?
Yeah, I did everything.
I had to restart every 5 games or something.
Wait, you got your Twitch Rivals money, didn't you?
Yeah, but I can't get a 50-90 anywhere.
They're impossible to find.
Yeah, I don't want to do the campout thing.
The nearest microcenter is...
I'll get one for you.
Please?
Are you going to campout?
I might do it again, just to get another one.
Wait, why do you need two?
I have a 50-80 right now.
So I just...
It barely performs better than a 40-80.
Wait, people are saying the 50-90 crash has a lot of problems right now, though.
There's some really bad driver things going on right now.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm back on.
Shoot me an invite, please.
Well, okay.
There's a thing that makes sense.
Usually, every release for newer GPUs always has a bunch of crashes.
So it's not really...
It's a really common thing at the beginning.
Oh, I see.
I don't think we have casters.
I think they left us.
Oh.
They're like, damn, this game is ass!
I think the casters aren't casting us anymore.
Is that it?
I checked their Twitch.
I'm confused.
Where did they go?
Let me check their Twitch.
Where did our casters go?
Did they leave us?
Do they just don't want to watch this anymore because we're going ghost?
Next match.
Team Jeff fan club.
Yeah, they left us.
What was that?
They left us after one game?
One game and they killed it?
Wait, but who's the leader?
I mean, too bad we're running Ghost Legends.
I guess we're making...
Oh, I guess one of us has to...
Wait, who's...
I guess we make a new lobby.
Let's just make a new lobby.
And we'll invite them in.
They're like, I'm not here to watch ghosts.
We want to watch DPS players.
Alright.
Let me...
Wait, sorry.
I was looking at something.
What did you say?
You're making a new lobby for us.
Am I?
Alright.
Boom.
I'll invite all of you.
No, wait.
I bought a battle.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's here.
It was like, me?
Oh, that's tough.
I gave you the ID for the other captain.
I went to my recent...
I failed to send a request.
I can invite them too.
Wait, they're in a room.
Why are they in a room?
We should...
Oh, okay.
We're supposed to join them.
Wait, but we're first.
We're the top.
I don't know.
They can be in charge of the room.
I don't care.
Oh, we left battle.
JK, you thought you were gonna play.
Okay, I got Shoto.
Yeah, I'm like...
Shoto, I'm not used to...
I'm used to everyone's names being at the top.
And yours is all the way down.
He has too many friends.
Wait, the caster came back.
Wait, they came back.
Oh, they came back?
I thought they didn't want to watch us anymore.
I didn't want to play anyway.
Okay, it's cool.
We are...
I'm sorry, battle.
Yeah, I said we are.
I like how he question marked you too.
Battle added Gomez.
That's cool.
I didn't want to play anyway.
I said we are ready.
So, whenever they are ready, we will start the game.
What map are we doing?
Oh, we are doing Koth.
It's Koth time.
One more game.
One more game and we are free.
And I don't think...
You are not gonna be late, right?
To your tournament.
Didn't he say it started at 3?
Yeah, 3 PST, right?
Oh, no.
Oh, he's not even there.
Oh, he's not alive.
Oh, this is...
No, I'm here.
Is your tournament starting at 3 PST?
3 PST or ESC?
Oh, it's already passed.
They are starting it.
Okay, we win this fast.
99-0.
They hope we will get to the next game.
I thought we had to do a grand final.
Or a winner's final.
That's tomorrow.
If we win this, we are done.
I guess we are done either way.
Bucky.
Are you okay?
Alright.
Are they gonna have a Star Lord?
Star Lord.
Oh, there it is.
Got him.
Looks like I'm on Magneto.
Oh, magic.
They want to do magic to counter it, probably.
Is that what I'm saying?
Since we have Jay, do we save Thing?
What do you want to do?
Because we need to save Magna.
We can save Thing.
Yeah, let's just save Thing.
I would like to save Thing for magic.
Venom is open by the way.
I can play Venom as well, if we need to.
Oh, we could.
Yeah.
Why don't we ban then?
Do we ban?
Namor or Luna?
Ban Luna again.
Luna?
Okay.
I'm down for that.
Get her out.
We just have a set ban line.
Which is pretty good.
So you can't play Luna anymore.
Yeah.
So we can run Flankers too if we want to.
Oh.
I'm going to be simple.
Alright.
I'm just the item player.
I'm Kurova, I guess.
Oh my god, are you going to kill everything?
No.
No, because I'm a team player.
Nah.
I like Adam.
I assume there's just too much stuff going on.
Yeah.
I'm too tired to think that far.
Oh, that's not good for you.
You have to play more games later.
Yeah, you have to play more.
You have to lock it in, bro.
We haven't done a domination in a second.
We did last match.
We did?
Oh my god, bro, my brain.
Yeah, because we hydrogen bombed them.
Oh, we hydrogen bombed them, that's why.
You guys didn't even notice it.
We had to hydrogen bomb this one too, guys.
This stuff was too hard.
Here we go.
Okay, so go through right room.
This one, this one, this one right here.
This one, this one.
Okay, let's go inside.
Are they main?
They're main.
Yep.
Do you have the thing?
Oh, I dropped down.
You got magic?
I picked up the magic.
I'm helping you, I'm helping you.
I'm soul bonding us, I'm soul bonding us.
I don't have any heals, I don't have any heals.
I don't have any heals here.
Yeah, I got it, I got it, I got it.
I am rezzing now.
I picked up the storm, I put them in.
Storm one.
Can we play this comp or swap?
I have to swap, I have to swap.
They can't kill me.
They already capped, so you guys have to die.
Yeah, okay.
They're gonna have storm ult, they have storm ult for this.
Yeah, I'm almost there.
I'll try to soul bond.
But we still need to use low heal, I think.
After the soul bond.
Oh my god.
Shoot the frontline, shoot frontline, shoot frontline.
Oh my god, a clobber.
I soul linked us.
They used two DPS ults here.
Can I ult when this is done?
I'll clob.
I'm going on point, okay?
I'm going on point, I'm going on point.
They're C laning, they're C laning.
I'm on the side right now.
I can TP to point at all of them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can.
I have heal.
I'm rezzing, I'm rezzing.
I got three, I got three.
I'm TPing, I'm TPing, I'm TPing.
Oh, it's too far.
I'm too far away.
Oh no, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm good, I'm good.
I don't have snaps right now.
Ding, ding, ding, ding.
We have one fight.
Cloak, cloak, cloak.
Moon knight on high ground.
He's at absolute one, absolute one, absolute one.
I don't know if we can get him.
I might swap to cloak.
Cloak, I don't think...
Alright, we have enough heals.
Oh, nice.
This one's a hard map to heal properly on.
Nice, oh my god.
Same thing, I can shift up and I can drop down.
Okay.
They have clobbering.
Yeah, yeah.
You're on magic, they'll have magic ult too.
I can only still link one of these.
They're not going main?
Are they not?
They're not, right?
Is it?
Yeah, I can look for it.
Oh my god.
Am I going ult?
Yeah, I don't think I can.
I don't have shift for like 10 seconds.
Magic's on me.
Magic ult.
Storm.
Storm ult.
I still linked up.
He missed, he missed.
Storm.
I'm holding it.
Magic ult.
Magic one, she got the health pack in mind.
I'm going to ult after the invis ult.
I'm looking for it.
I don't have soul link.
Two, two, two, two.
I got one.
Good job, good job.
Last fight, last fight.
Gotcha.
Nice job.
Very nice, very very nice.
They have storm ult.
They're changing, they're changing.
They're portaling, portaling.
I have ult up for this.
They're going to storm ult.
We have a free cone ult.
I have ult.
Holding point, holding point.
We have two ults soon.
Wait, he went main?
Wait, what?
Wait, magic, yeah?
Magic, yeah?
Wait, what?
Wait, that's like...
He canceled his TP.
There's no soul link.
It's okay, it's okay.
Nice, that's so good, that's so good.
Everybody's dead.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Stop straight lining.
There's supposed to straight line.
I hate that.
Hahaha.
That's crazy.
They don't have portal.
I hate that map so much.
Okay, I'll still say Adam then.
Because we made it work in the end.
Alright, one more, one more.
I think I was able to heal properly at a better angle too.
It was like so much of a mess at the first part.
When we were grabbing point.
Okay, so they went, they did storm ult.
They should have less support.
They have a cloak ult.
They haven't used it at all.
Did they?
They used it in the fight before, so they might have it.
Yeah, they might have it here.
We could engage with the Psylocke ult.
And see if they do have...
Yeah, see if we do have support here.
We can put you...
What we can do is we can put you all the way in the right room.
On the high ground.
We can just all int in, and then you get your rez ready.
And then we can all get rezzed again.
Okay, I can do that.
I'll just go right then.
I'll go flank.
I'm going the right side, so don't follow me.
Alright, I'm as a loner.
Leave her alone.
Oh, I'm hit.
Are they on...
Magic...
Moon Knight...
Are they running the same thing?
Not the exact same thing.
Where's Namor?
They have Namor.
They have Namor now.
I'm one.
It's fine.
Got one.
I got the...
I'm on Sue.
I'm killing you.
I got you.
My damage doesn't matter.
We got Sue.
Get the Namor.
He has no...
Kill him!
Okay, I'm one.
Oh, wait.
You got bounced away.
I don't have snap.
I got it now.
I'm backing up.
Back up.
I can look for a massive ult here.
They should have thing ult, right?
Probably.
They should have Moon Knight too.
I ult here.
I just need Lime near me.
Okay, get Lime.
Nice.
Good pick.
Play around the corner here.
Nice.
Alright, if you want to 1v6, man.
I'm literally just standing here.
He died, came back, and killed you.
That's crazy.
Alright, we can look for a big ult here.
Do we look for it?
I'm kinda down to look for this.
3, 2, 1.
Big.
Nice.
Yeah.
There's a magic behind you.
Magic.
Oh, I didn't see her.
You didn't see her?
I didn't even see her, bro.
That's all me, bro.
My bad.
Oh, I didn't see you.
Our child.
My bad, bro.
Am I inting?
Oh, I am.
Maybe.
I don't have Soul Bond anymore, so that's awesome.
Let me get in there.
I'm low.
I'm trying to heal.
I'm trying so hard.
Oh my god, it's Big Clubber.
Looks like a Big Clubber.
I couldn't do it.
That's so fucking good.
Why the fuck are you Spider-Man?
I'm Spider-Man.
Spider-Man.
I'm really Spider-Man.
Oh, Spider-Man.
I'm going back.
I'm done.
I think...
Who called Spider-Man?
Who fucking asked?
Who changed to Spider-Man?
I wonder.
Are we portaling or are we just going?
Yeah, we can portal.
Where do we portal to?
You know, we just have to do it on point.
I'll just do it on point.
We'll do the MMO thing.
Yeah, I'm good.
I'll do the MMO thing and then I'll do the usual.
I can look for Ola as well.
Counter Ola.
There.
Oh my god, it's massive.
It's everywhere.
I'm slapping Strange.
I'm body blocking Magic.
I can kill her.
No more!
Goodbye!
Goodbye, no more!
Nice.
Is he portaling?
There's no way he can do it in time.
Yeah, GG!
GG!
We did it!
We got it!
Are we done for today?
Yeah, we did it.
Thank god.
We should have.
Let me double check.
Let me check.
We're 9-1, right?
Yeah, we only had one tie, so we make it.
So we're automatic winners.
Because the second place team has two ties.
Hell yeah.
We did it.
I'm so proud of us, guys.
I'm proud of y'all.
Each game, we all get better and better.
Also good.
In this one comp we play.
Our very favorite comp.
We keep banning out everything else.
It's not our fault!
It's not our fault they target banned Gomez.
Yeah, I love that.
We could play like real comps if they didn't ban Starlord.
This is Starlord ban every game.
It's not our fault.
GG's though, I'm proud of us.
Good stuff, guys.
Yeah, GG's.
We all did really well.
Plus Battle too.
All of us did really, really well.
Plus Battle.
I think this comp we're playing is super...
We have to be really coordinated as a team to play this comp.
We're so...
Yeah, coordination here.
When he killed that one guy, then he came back from spawn just to kill him?
No, no, no.
I looked back.
I looked at Cocam.
I jumped into his shots.
That doesn't make you look better, Gomez.
He didn't even aim.
He looked at one direction in each shot.
And I died.
GG's, Battle.
Good Magneto, Battle.
You actually got the play of the game, Battle.
You guys did really great though.
You guys did really good.
Yeah, I'm proud of us.
Yeah, I'll see you guys at 8am, everybody.
Oh no, that's PST.
Yeah, PST.
I'll see you at 8am.
Y'all better be sleeping, bro.
Oh no, I'm definitely sleeping early today.
I'm gonna try and like, work until I'm fucking exhausted by the end of the day so I can actually sleep this time.
Alright, GG's.
It was great playing with you guys for day one.
See you guys tomorrow.
GG's.
Bye bye, guys.
Bye bye.
Oh my god!
We made it to winners!
I'm so happy!
I'm so happy that we all made it to winners with this scummy comp.
Yeah, we all did really well.
I'm really proud of our team, like I said.
We started from our first scrim to now.
We all did really really well.
And this is the most Adam I've played too.
In the scrims, we were playing Luna.
I was mostly playing Luna.
I think I would play Adam once every scrim.
So this is the most I've ever had to play Adam in a long time.
So I'm happy I was able to do the things I can do as Adam with the lack of practice.
So yeah, because Naimo and Shota they got practice.
We put more so, instead of Adam, we did Luna instead.
But we felt like Adam was better against the stronger teams.
But yeah, thank you everybody!
That was fun.
It started off like slow because I was tired as fuck, but I hit my second win.
And I'm really happy with how much we all improved.
Thank you for the raid, Feta!
Thank you!
But I am incredibly happy with how well everybody performed individually and as a team and all our comms and stuff like that.
I'm really proud of our team and everything.
And the shots that we were doing and what we came up with.
When we realized what we were doing wrong we figured things out instantly.
We got better.
You know what I mentioned?
Oh, we need to be more proactive in swaps.
We instantly became more proactive in swapping when things don't work so that we could hydrogen bomb our opponents so we could get like, you know, so we don't have to play losers brackets.
So I'm really proud.
I'm really proud of everybody on this team.
I'm super happy with how everyone was doing.
And everybody improved so fucking much.
Like, Beto used to be like, used to just play mag, but now he can play like a lot of different tanks and everything ever since our first scrim.
And you know, I just love the improvement that everyone had.
And like, Coney learning the thing as well.
And you know, Laimu and Shoto being able to flex to being able to flex to like different supports for us.
Because Laimu didn't have Adam as her hero pool.
And Shoto was supposed to be like the main of the DPS, but he was able to flex to Loki, which helped a lot as well.
And yeah, like Laimu literally learned Adam in two weeks.
And her Adam is insane.
Her Adam is really really good for like what we're dealing with.
The fact that we didn't have like that many scrims compared to like some of the teams.
Like some teams were scrimming like almost every day.
So I'm really happy like the progress we've did to be able to go into winner's bracket.
But yes!
Yeah!
Thank you everyone!
Thank you everybody!
And also the progress between Jay too.
We actually have like comps with Jay that we haven't even tried yet.
Because we didn't bump into an occasion where we have to try it.
So I'm really proud of everybody.
But I'll see you guys on day two!
Day two!
We have day two.
It's the winner's bracket.
I think it's around it's eliminate.
I don't know how many games we're playing for winner's bracket.
But
we are playing against group G I believe.
I think it's group G.
I don't fucking know.
I'm gonna research the team later after everybody's done with their games.
Yeah, it's gonna be same time guys.
It's gonna start at 8am PST.
So it's gonna be the same time.
But yes!
Thank you everyone!
Thank you all for watching!
I hope you guys enjoyed watching competitive Marble Rivals.
I'm so happy with how well we've done for our first for my first real tournament and how well my team did.
Thank you everybody for watching guys!
As always everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you did that for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'm gonna rest my voice now.
I shot called a lot with our other... I co-IGL'd a lot and had to alt track and everything.
And like micro macro... help... micro macro so my voice is tired.
So I'll see you guys next time.
I'll see you guys tomorrow!
Bye guys!
Bye!
I'm trying to find my ending screen.
Okay there you go.
Bye!